ARCHULETA ADKINS BAIT- FORGES
BRADFORD BY ADAM CORTEZ V.
DALLY DODD THEY'RE AWESOME
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALES GROVE
HERZBERG WEST SO HER TADO JONES
CAM WALKER LAYERED LABOR LET
ALONE THE GLIDER MELINDA'S MAN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH
PAN FORTUNE TINO RALPH RUBIO
SKINNER STERN AMBERG WHAT
COUNTS SKI WEINER. WELL. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AT OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR DRAWS SO. AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. BY SENATOR UMBERG.
CENTER DRAWS A- THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. PART OF THE
GENERATIONS WHEN WE SET OUR
HANDS TO LABOR THINKING THAT WE
WORK ALONE. REMIND US THAT WE
CARRY ON OUR LIPS THE WORDS OF
PROFITS. IN OUR VEINS THE BLOOD
OF MARTYRS IN OUR EYES THE
MYSTICS VISIONS. AND IN OUR
HANDS THE STRENGTH OF THOUSANDS
AMON. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE-
WHEN WE SAY THE PLEDGE TODAY
PLEASE KEEP IN MIND THE ELEVEN
MARINES ONE SOLDIER AND ONE
SAILOR. WHO HAD THEIR LIVES
TAKEN FROM ALL OF US AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THOSE WHO WERE
WOUNDED. IN THE SERVICE OF
THEIR COUNTRY SAVING THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF LIVES. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE HAVE A LOT OF
BUSINESS TO GET THROUGH THIS
AFTERNOON SO IF WE CAN GET THE
SENATORS ON THE FLOOR. AND
READY TO. DO THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS TODAY THAT WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED- MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS ON COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED RED AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NOW TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE
WEEK OF AUGUST TWENTY THIRD
THROUGH TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL BE APPROVING
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
THERE ARE FLOOR AMENDMENTS AT
THE DESK THEY WILL BE DEEMED
ADOPTED. AND ANY. MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED IN OUR
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THING
NONE WE WILL MOVE ON. TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILES SECOND READING CLARK
PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY NINE FORTY
SIX FORTY EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
SECOND READING WILL BE DEEMED
RED WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE
HAVE ITEMS. ONE THIRTY THREE
ONE THIRTY FIVE ONE THIRTY
EIGHT ONE THIRTY NINE AND ONE
FORTY ONE UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS SENATOR BATES WILL
BE PRESENTING ALL THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT SENATOR
BATES YOU MAY OPEN ON. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE IS
A CONFIRMATION OF MICHAEL
EHRLICH TO THE HASTINGS COLLEGE
OF LAW BOARD OF DIRECTORS
REBECCA FOSTER TO THE HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION BOARD
OF DIRECTORS. DAVE BRANCH TO
THE HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
CORPORATION BOARD OF DIRECTORS
AND JOSEPH TEMBO LOANEE TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. ALL
OF THESE APPOINTMENTS WERE
APPROVED ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE IN
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST EIGHTEENTH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENTS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FACE I
BACKER. FIVE FORGES BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM. CORTEZ THREE FIVE
DALLY. DOT THEY'RE ALSO I
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER ARE YOU
CONSOLIDATE OUR GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HER TADO
ARE YOU JONES I CAN LONGER.
LAYERED I FLAVOR. HI THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW BOTH
HI PAM HI FORTUNE TINO. ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERN
AMBERG I WORK OUT SKI I WINNER
I WILL. HI SENATOR BATES WAS A
CALL CENTER BEIJING MAY OPEN ON
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE. YEAH
I. THINK. IS IT ON NOW OKAY-
ONE THIRTY FIVE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF THE FALLING
WATER QUALITY CONTROL BOARD
APPOINTMENTS DR MONICA HUNTER
TO THE CENTRAL COAST REGIONAL
BOARD FOR LEFT HAND TO THE SAN
DIEGO BOARD JANE BADDIE AND
DONALD YOUNG TO THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY BOARD AND LETITIA
CLARK TO THE SANTA ANA BOARD
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST EIGHTEENTH. ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I FACE HI BECKER I
PORGES I BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I
COURTESY. FIVE DALLY I DON HI
TORONTO I HATE. EYE LASER FIVE
DOLLARS HI GROSS I HURTS BERG I
WAS SO. HER TADO I JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON. MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S.
MAN HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I GO
TO A VOTE I CAN I PERSON TINA.
BROUGHT I REVIEW HI SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBERED HI WHAT KASKY
FIVE WINNER I WILL HI SENATOR
BATES WAS THE CALL CENTER BASED
YOU MAY OPEN ON ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
EIGHT IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
PABLO BRIE AS CHAIR OF THE
GAMBLING CONTROL COMMISSION.
MATH LIVERY IF AN TTORNEY AND
HAVE SERVED ON THE COMMISSION
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN. PRIOR
TO THIS APPOINTMENT SHE WAS
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH ON A AND M. S. FIVE
ZERO VOTE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I HAD
CANS FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER. I
PORCHES HI BRADFORD HI BY ADAM
HI CORTESE HI DALLY I DON FIVE
TORONTO I HAD BEEN. I GLAZER
FIVE DOLLARS HI GROSS OUR
RECORDS WORK I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON. THE
CHOIR HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN I A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO.
RALPH I RUBIO IVE SKINNER HI
STERN- BERG I WORK OUT SKI I
WINNER I WILL HI. SENATOR BATES
MOVES THE CALL CENTER BASE
LET'S MOVE ON A FILE AND A ONE
THIRTY NINE. FILE ITEM. ONE
THIRTY NINTH OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF KATHLEEN DOES
SHE ON ME TO THE GAMBLING
CONTROL COMMISSION. MANY OF US
HAVE THE PLEASURE OF SERVING A
LONG FIGHT TO SENATOR DASCHLE
ANI DURING OUR TIME HERE IN THE
SENATE. FROM TWENTY TWELVE TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY FROM 200-062-2012 SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE. ON AUGUST
EIGHTEENTH ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SAYING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA. FIVE ADKINS HI BABES
HI BECKER. HI PORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T HI
CORTESE HI SALLY. FIVE DOT I
TORONTO FIVE EGGMAN HI GLAZER.
HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS WORLD HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON
MCGUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S MIN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF
BOTH HI CAN I FORTUNE TINO.
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN NUMBER FIVE WHITE HOUSE
SKI FIVE WINNER. I WILL HI
SENATOR BATES MOVES THE CALL
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
FINAL GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
IT'S A FILE AND ONE FORTY ONE
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF YOUR
RECEIPT TO THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION. MR YEE WAS A
DISTRICT ATTORNEY INVESTIGATOR
IN THE ORANGE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN A POLICE
OFFICER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT HE ALSO
SERVED AS A MARINE RESERVE IN
THE UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON A UNANIMOUS FIVE
ZERO VOTE ON AUGUST EIGHTEENTH
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE OF THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
FIVE EIGHT FIVE BACKER. FIVE
PORCHES HI BRADFORD I COME BY
ADAM FIVE OR TEN THIRTY I DALLY.
I DON. HI TORONTO I A GIVEN.
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS
HI HURTS BERG HI WITH SO FIVE
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON HI
THERE HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
BOTH I CAN. FIVE FORTUNE TINO
RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN AMBERG ALL RIGHT I WAKE
OUT SKIING HI WINNER I WILL. HI.
THANK YOU M. SECTOR THAT'S THE
FINAL GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
WE HAVE THOSE ON FILE MEMBERS
WERE GONNA MOVE TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FOR THE SENATE. I'M
SORRY. I'M SORRY SENATOR BATES
MOVES A CALL ON THAT LAST ITEM.
AND WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. AND WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE AND. ONE
FORTY NINE ONE FIFTY ONE FIFTY
TO ONE FIFTY THREE AND SEVERAL
MORE AFTER THAT WHEN START WITH
FILE AND A ONE FORTY NINE.
WHICH IS SENATOR RUBIO CENTER
RUBIO'S READY CENTER REVEAL
YOUR RECOGNIZED. GIVE ME A
COUPLE DAYS OFF I GOT TO BE
RETRAINED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL UP PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ELEVEN BY SENATOR RUBIO
RELATIVE TO THE CANCER PATIENTS
BILL OF RIGHTS NOW SENATOR
RUBIO THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
STR ELEVEN THE CANCER PATIENT
BILL OF RIGHTS THAT'S A ME MATE
MINOR AMENDMENTS NOT
SUBSTANTIVE THE RESOLUTION HAS
PASSED WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL. THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS HI
PLEASE. HI BACKER HI PORCHES I
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
CORTESE I DALLY. I DONT. I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN I BELIEVE HER.
HI GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH I HEARD
BERG HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I.
LEIVA. HI THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN.
NIELSEN I GO TO A VOTE. HI TAM
HI FOURTEEN TO NO. RALPH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN
AMBERG HI QUITE HOW SKI I
WINNER. I WILL. HI SENATOR
RUBIO MOVES A CALL NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
WHICH IS SENATOR WIENER.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TEN BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE CENTER
WINNER I THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES SP TIME HAS RETURNED
ON CONCURRENCE. AS YOU RECALL
OF THIS LEGISLATION OR THIS
BILL IS COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY
FOR CITIES- GIVES US IT IS A-
VOLUNTARY- STREAMLINED- PROCESS
FOR REZONING NON SPRAWL AREAS
FOR SMALL MULTI UNITS- WE- IN
THE ASSEMBLY WE REMOVED IT'S
ALWAYS FROM THE BILL- IN
ADDITION- MADE CLEAR THAT OPEN
SPACE AND SIMILAR- BALLOT
MEASURES COULD NOT BE IMPACTED
BY THE BILL. IN ADDITION TO
OTHER- TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS-
COLORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. WILL. THANK SENATOR
WIENER THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON SB TEN ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SINGH NATT YES SIR
CENTER GLAZIER. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IN HIS WHOLE-
HOUSING SPACE THERE'S BEEN A
SPIRITED DEBATE ACROSS THE
STATE THIS YEAR AND IN THE PAST
YEARS FOR GOOD REASON. WE HAVE
A HOUSING CRISIS AND I
APPRECIATED ADMIRE ALL THE
AUTHORS AND- BUT MANY
COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE FLOOR
WHO HAVE. I STEPPED INTO THIS
SPACE. WITH THOUGHTFULNESS.
WITH RESPONSIVENESS TO THE
CONCERNS THAT OUR RESIDENTS
HAVE OUR CITIES HAVE. AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. GIVEN ALL
THOSE CONCERNS ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL THAT I STAND HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN. I
BELIEVE THIS BILL EMBODIES THE
CONCERNS THAT MANY OF US HAVE.
THAT THESE CHOICES ON HOUSING
SHOULD BE DONE IN A WAY THAT'S
RESPONSIVE TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THIS BILL DOES
JUST THAT. IT PUTS THE POWER
COMPLETELY IN THE HANDS OF
LOCAL. JURISDICTIONS TO UTILIZE
THE TOOLS IN THIS BILL OR NOT.
YEAH YEAH TELL ONE PARTICULAR
CONCERN THAT'S BEEN EXPRESSED
HIS. THE CONCERN THAT A LOCAL
CITY COUNCIL. CAN OVERRIDE. HEY
LOCALLY APPROVED REFERENDUM OR
INITIATIVE IN THIS AREA OF LAND
USE THE AUTHOR IS TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE
POTENTIAL- LIKELIHOOD OF THAT
OCCURRING THAT IS ALSO RAISE
THE THRESHOLD FOR ANY SUCH
ACTION TO TWO THIRDS VOTE. OF
THOSE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FOR
MANY CITIES THAT HAVE FIVE
MEMBERS OF THEIR COUNSEL IN
ESSENCE IT WOULD REQUIRE 80%
TWO I DECIDE TO TAKE SUCH AN
ACTION AND OF COURSE TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR ANY SUCH
ACTION AND AS FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT I STAND HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TAX. THANK YOU SARAH GLAZER
SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO ECHO- WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE FROM AROUND IT
JUST SAID- I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
FEEDBACK AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE
A SPIRITED DEBATE IN ORANGE
COUNTY OVER THIS BILL- THE FACT
OF THE MATTER IS THAT WE IN THE
STATE ARE FACING A HOUSING
CRISIS AND IT IS A CRISIS. I
GUESS THE NUMBER ONE REASON
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE STATE-
IT'S A CHALLENGE TO OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT'S A CHALLENGE FOR
NEW ENTRANTS IT'S BECOME A
BARRIER TO PRODUCTIVITY AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH IN THE STATE WE
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT TO
BALANCE THOSE CONCERNS. ARE
WITH THE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS OF
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO KEEP THE
CHARACTER THEIR COMMUNITIES WHO
WANT TO KEEP THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS- THE WAY THEY
WERE WHEN THEY BOUGHT THEM AND
I THINK THIS BILL DOES THAT IF
HE DOES A GOOD JOB OF BOUNCING
BETWEEN COMPETING CONCERNS ALL
RECOGNIZING THAT WE ARE IN A
HOUSING CRISIS- AND I APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR MICHAEL THE
CONSENSUS GO FOR CONTINUING TO
BE OPEN TO TAKING AMENDMENTS TO
ENSURE. THAT WE HAVE A LIGHT
TOUCH LOCAL CONTROL ORIENTED
APPROACH- BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE
PROGRESS- SO I WENT TO A
SUPPORT THIS BILL AGAIN AND I
THINK THE AUTHOR FROM SAN CISCO
FOR ALL HIS HARD WORK ON. THANK
YOU SENATOR MAN ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS ARE
MAKING SOME ODD MINUTES TO THE
BILL THAT WERE OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN REGARDING THE IMPACTS
TO OUR RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITIES-
AND IN PARTICULAR ON THE
PROVISIONS THAT ARE PROVIDED
THROUGH CCN OURS WHICH ARE
CONTRACT OBLIGATIONS- I'M NOT
SURE I UNDERSTOOD THAT YOU ALSO
REMOVED THE- ABILITY OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO OVERRIDE. A
CITIZENS INITIATIVE OUR
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR IS THAT
CORRECT. CENTER IN ORDER. YES
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM SO THE-
WHAT WE DID WE CHANGE THAT
PROVISION- SO THAT- CITY
COUNCIL CANNOT DO ANYTHING THE
TYPES- AND OPEN SPACE
PROTECTION GREEN BELL. PART
ACTION ATLANTA PROTECTION
THAT'S ALL JUST DONE EXCLUDED
FROM THE BELL CATEGORICALLY
FRANKLY WAS PROBABLY NEVER IN
THERE BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN FILL
DEVELOPMENT WE MADE A VERY
EXPLICIT AND NUMBER THOSE
LIMITED MEASURES THAT COULD BE
IMPACTED OTHER THAN ALL THE
OPEN SPACE ARE GROUNDED CETERA
ON THE REQUIRED TWO THIRDS VOTE
OF THE COUNCIL SO WE TIGHTENED
IT UP DRAMATICALLY- AND I
NARROWED DRAMATICALLY. THANK
YOU ON MY OWN TIME ON MISTER
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO READ IF I
MIGHT A JUDGMENT THAT JUST CAME
FORWARD FROM THE HEART. A JUDGE
OF THE SUPERIOR COURT IN SAN
DIEGO REGARDING- OF. ONE OF MY
CITIES A CITY OF ANTHONY DOVE
FOUNDATION REGARDING OUR THEIR
PROPOSITION A WHICH IS A LOCAL
INITIATIVE REGARDING OUR
DEVELOPMENT IT SAYS STATE LAW
PROVIDES SUBSTANTIAL TOOLS OF
ENFORCEMENT. TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS- OF AN ADEQUATE
HOUSING ELEMENT INVALIDATING
THE CITIZENS RIGHT TO VOTE
SHOULD ONLY BE A LAST RESORT.
WEIGHING THE EVIDENCE BEFORE
THE COURT THE PRESENT DISPUTE
HAS NOT REACHED THIS LEVEL. FOR
THE FOREGOING REASONS REQUEST A
DECLARATORY AND INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF IS DENIED AND I BRING
THAT UP BECAUSE I AM VERY
PLEASED THAT THE COURT. IS
GIVING A VERY SIGNIFICANT ROLE
IN ONTO THE VOICE OF THE PEOPLE
AND I THINK WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL THAT THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE ON THESE PARTICULAR
INITIATIVES REGARDING. LOCAL
PHONING SINGLE FAMILY ARE HUGE
WE HAD FOUR PAGES OF CITY
COUNCILS AND OTHER GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
REGISTERED THEIR OPPOSITION
THEY HAVE SPECIFICALLY CITED
SOME VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES SIZE
OF LOT. PARKING RESTRICTIONS
ALL OF THESE EFFECTS. ARE
CERTAINLY PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES AND A LOT OF
CONSTERNATION COMES TO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SPECIFICALLY
REGARDING. THE THE SETBACKS THE
NOISE IMPACTS CAN CERTAINLY
ACCESS TO THOSE PARTICULAR LOTS
BY PUBLIC SAFETY. PERSONNEL SO
I WILL REMAIN OPPOSED TO THESE
UNTIL THOSE PARTICULAR CONCERNS
ARE ADDRESSED AND HOPEFULLY
THEY WOULD COME FORWARD- TOO
WAS ON MAN AND SOME OF THESE
MEASURES AND WE GO FORWARD. AS
WE SEE THEY BEGIN TO IMPACT.
ARE SOME OF THE STANDARDS THAT
HAVE COME FROM THE URBAN LAND
INSTITUTE OVER MANY MANY YEARS
THESE THINGS HAVE BEEN.
DISCUSSED AND IMPLEMENTED TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE RESPECTING
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES IMPACTS
THAT DO PUT ON PEOPLE'S LIVES
IN DANGER AND CERTAINLY OUT OF
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE GOING TO INHABIT. MULTI
FAMILY SINGLE FAMILY WHATEVER.
IT REALLY IMPACTS ALL OF THEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANY OTHER DISK OR- ON FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTEEN SPEED TEN. ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER WINNER YOU MAY CLOSE. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM IRVINE AND- END UP FOR
REALLY REMINDING PEOPLE WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT WE'VE- YOU
KNOW IN THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS AS I'VE- BEEN UP AND DOWN
THE STATE TALKING TO LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS. RESIDENTS
ABOUT HOUSING- AND CITIES IN
PARTICULAR WOULD HAVE TOLD ME
SO MANY TIMES PLEASE GIVE US
MORE TOOLS SO THAT WE CAN DO
THE THINGS THAT YOU WANT US TO
DO. PLEASE MAKE IT EASIER AND
LESS EXPENSIVE- AND SO WE DON'T
GET SUED AS MUCH- AND MAKE OUR
LIVES EASIER THAT'S WHAT SB TEN
DOTS. AND TWO CENTS RIGHT
CALLING FROM OTHER GONNA GUY
PUSHES THOSE COMMENTS NOTHING
IN THIS BILL. IMPACTS THE
CITY'S ABILITY TO DO ANYTHING
THEY WANT TO AROUND SEPT BACKS
OR- PARKING OR ANYTHING ELSE
ALL THIS DOES IS GIVE THEM AN
OPTIONAL LOCAL CONTROL-
DECISION MAKING POWER- TO- TO
HIS OWN PERSONAL MOTOR UNIT OR
NOT- THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND
COLLEAGUES. I RESPECT US FOR
NOVEL. THIS AND DEBATE IT HAS
CONCLUDED SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. FIVE EIGHT NO BACKER.
PORGES BRADFORD I HAVE A LOT OF
I. CORTEZ HE- HI DALLY FIVE DOT
FIVE TORONTO I HAD BEEN HI
GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH HI HURTS BERG. WHAT I
FOUND I- TADA HI JONES I CAN'T
MARKER. LAYERED NO LLEVA I LIVE
ALONE. THE CHOIR I MELINDA'S.
MAN FIVE NEWMAN. NIELSEN FIVE
HOTEL OKAY HI PAM I FORTINO NO
BROAD FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
HI STERN I'M BURKE I LIKE HOW
SKI. HI WINNER I WILL KNOW.
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE AND
MEMBERS. ALAN BECKER. FOR JUST
I. HERTZBERG NO CAM AUGER NO
LET ALONE. MELINDA'S NEWMAN.
STERN. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
SIX MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON A FILE AND ONE
FIFTY TWO. WHICH IS A SENATOR
OF THE MALL CINEMA ON ON ITEM
ONE FIFTY TWO THANK YOU.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY NINE BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AN ACT
RELATING TO GOVERNMENT FINANCED.
CEREMONY THANK YOU S. B. TWO
THIRTY NINE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
STATE TREASURER FIONA MA AND
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
IN THE MANAGEMENT OF THE STATE
SURPLUS FUNDS. AMENDMENTS WERE
MADE IN THE ASSEMBLY TO AVOID
CAPTURING OUT PROVISIONS OF AB
EIGHT SIX NINE WHICH IS ALSO
SPONSORED BY THE TRAIN STATE
TREASURER BUT STILL HAS NOT
RECEIVED RECEIVED ANY VOTES IN
US OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN ITEM. THANK YOU
CEREMONY IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE AT
A ONE FIFTY TWO ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SORRY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
FIVE ADKINS FIVE BABIES FIVE
BACKER. I PORCHES. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I PROTESTING HI
DALLY I DONT. HI THERE AWESOME
HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG FIVE WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MOON. HI
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S FIVE
MILLION FIVE NEWMAN I NEED
NIELSEN. I GO TO A VOTE HI PAM
I FORTUNES INNER. HI RALPH I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
HI WHAT KASKI I WINNER I WILL
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR JEFF I EARN. SIZE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR- FOR
SENATOR HUESO WILL BE
RECOGNIZED AS SOON ACQUIRES US
IN A WAY SO HAS GAS PRODUCED IN
THE GALLERY SENATOR WAY SO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS I RISE TO PERCENT. THE
GOVERNOR ELECT OF NEW WAVERLY
ON. MEDICAL DOCTORS SOMEONE GOT
TO SEE A WHICH IS HERE VISITING
US FROM A NORMAL ON. MEXICO HE
BEGAN HIS POLITICAL CAREER AS
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER NORMALLY
OWNS SEVENTY FOURTH STATE
LEGISLATURE FOLLOWED BY- BEING
ELECTED. TO THE NATIONAL CENTER
pIS GOING TO BE THE NEXT
GOVERNOR OF NORMALLY ON TAKE UP
BEGINNING IN OCTOBER. W. IT IS.
VERY IMPORTANT STATE TO MEXICO
HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
ECONOMIES IN MEXICO IT IS A
INDUSTRIAL. CITY AT THE IT HAS
SOME- INVESTS IN AERONAUTICS
BIOTECHNOLOGY. OF MECHATRONICS
INFORMATION AND COMMUNICATION
TECHNOLOGIES. AND HE IS HERE
VISITING CALIFORNIA TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
FIGHT FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
TO SUPPORT. A RENEWABLE ECONOMY
SO- WE ARE WORKINGTOGETHER ON
THAT HE IS PLEDGED TO. YOU KNOW
CLEAN THE AIR QUALITY IN THE
STATE OF NOT ONLY ON AND HELP
TO INTRODUCE A CONTINUED
INTRODUCED TECHNOLOGIES ARE
GOING TO HELP THE STATE
PROSPER. IN AREAS OF FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE SO PLEASE JOIN
ME. IN WELCOMING DR SOMEONE'S
GOT TO SEE A- DENTIST WIFE.
WELCOME GOVERNOR ELECT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WELCOME
SOON WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU CONTINUOUSLY THREE
YEAR TERM THANK YOU. MEMBERS
WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO FILE AND ONE FIFTY
THREE. WHICH IS A SENATOR
SKINNER CENTERS SKINNER IS
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING. SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THAT'S B. TWO
NINETY IS BACK FOR CONCERT
CURRENTS IT'S PART OF THE
HOUSING PACKAGE SENATE'S
HOUSING PACKAGE AND BASICALLY
OUR HOUSES VOTED ON THIS BILL
IT WAS A BILL. I'VE
REINTRODUCED S. P. TEN EIGHTY
FIVE WHICH PASSED- JUST DIDN'T
MAKE IT BACK ON THAT LAST DAY
TO US- AND- SO HERE'S OUR
OPPORTUNITY AND I HOPE YOU WILL
SUPPORT AS YOU HAVE IN THE
PAST. JUST VERY QUICKLY IT
UPDATES THE STATE'S DENSITY
BONUS LAW TO ALLOW FOR STUDENT
HOUSING WHICH RIGHT NOW I WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW AND IT HELPS
THE DENSITY BNUS LAW CONFORM.
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS IN OUR
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON FILE AT A ONE FIFTY THREE SP.
TWO NINETY ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THINGS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER. I PORCHES NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A HYPERTENSIVE I DALLY
DODD FIVE THERE ARE SO. I A
GUNMAN HI BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES I DROVE. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO FIVE HER TADO I
JONES NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED.
HI LABOUR HI THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO- TELEVOTE. HI PAM
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. I BROUGHT. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SCARY
HI WINNER. I WILL. MEMBERS WILL
GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE MORE
TIME AND THEN CLOSE THE ROLE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSA MEMBERS.
TALLY GROVE. MELINDA'S STERN.
FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR A
SIMILAR AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO A FILE AND ONE FIFTY
FOUR SENATOR WILK. IS READY FOR
ONE FIFTY FOUR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO NINETY
TWO BY SENATOR WEALTH AN ACT
RELATING TO INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS REPRESENT- SP TWO
NINETY TWO REGARDING INDUSTRIAL
HEMP WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL SIMPLY
CONFIRMS CURRENT STATE LAW TO
THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE'S INTERIM FINAL
RULE REGARDING REPORTING AND
TESTING OF INDUSTRIAL HEMP IN
THE UNITED STATES. THIS MEASURE
HAS NO OPPOSITION IS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I BOTH. NUMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. CENTER GROVE
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- EXCUSE ME MR
PRESIDENT APOLOGIZE MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ALIGN CALIFORNIA
POLICY WITH USDA POLICY SO THAT
AND PEOPLE THAT ARE PROVIDING
INDUSTRIAL HIM FOR. A NEW
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD SO PLEASE VOTE YES
CENTER GROVE ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
AND ONE FIFTY FOUR. SENATOR
WILL CURE WHAT WILL RECOGNIZE
FOR CLOSURE IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO COLLAPSE ELECTRICAL I WANTED
THANK YOU- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
KERN COUNTY FOR COMMENTS AND
MOST IMPORTANT THING I BELIEVE
INDUSTRIAL HEMP IS GOING TO
REVOLUTIONIZE. AGRICULTURE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TAKES VERY LITTLE
WATER NO TO LITTLE NO TO LITTLE
PESTICIDES AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS WE'VE LEARNED HOW TO
PELLA TIES HIM UP. SO ANYTHING
YOU CAN DO WITH PLASTIC WHICH
IS CARBON BASED YOU CAN NOW DO
WITH INDUSTRIAL HEMP SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I VOTE THANK YOU SIR WILKES
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE HAS
CONCLUDED ON THIS ITEM MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
SEARCH FOR OKAY- NO OBJECTION-
EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
MIMICKING AMENDMENT ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WERE GONNA GO TO FILE
AND ONE FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
DRAWS- ON SP TWO NINETY SEVEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR ALSO AN ACT RELATING TO
SUB SERVICE INSTALLATIONS
CENTER DRUGS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS B. TWO NINETY
SEVEN WOULD CREATE A CIVIL
PENALTY OF UP TO ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN
OPERATOR OR EXCAVATOR. WHO
AFTER FAILING TO FOLLOW DID
ALERT REQUIREMENTS DAMAGES THE
SUB SERVICE INSTALLATION AND
CAUSES THE RELEASE OF HAZARDOUS
GAS OR LIQUID ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING THE NATURE AND WERE
MADE AT THE REQUEST OF CAL
FIRE. THIS MEASURE IS UNOPPOSED
AND HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS IN
CONCURRENCE WITH ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU SINNERS
ROUSERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS IS ALSO QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
MINISTER CONCURRED IN EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM ONE
FIFTY SIX CENTER ADMIN ON SP
FIVE OH SEVEN. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ THAT ABOUT FIVE OH SEVEN
BY SENATOR EDMUND AN ACT
RELATING TO MENTAL HEALTH
CENTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT S. B. FIVE OH SEVEN
IS BACK A CONVERSION IS SIMPLY
IMPROVING OUR MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE FOR THIS-
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS BUILT.
VERY EXCELLENT SPEECH CENTER
ADMIN IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS THIS ALSO
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM SEEING NONE EYES
THIRTY NINE IT KNOWS IT'S ZERO
MAJOR PASSES I'M SORRY IT'S IN
THE ASSEMBLY MA'AM IT'S OUR
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS REMOVING
TO FILE AND ONE FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR BECKER ON SP. FIVE
NINETY ONE SENATOR BECKER. IN
THE MIDDLE OF CENTER- SURGERY
PLEASE RE. SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR BACKER AN
ACT RELATING TO CIVIL LAW.
CENTER BACKER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT- THIS
PAST DECEMBER BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS JUST
CLARIFIED THE DEPLOYMENT OF
ENERGIZED INTERGENERATIONAL
HOUSING DOES NOT IMPACT TAX
BENEFIT ALLOCATIONS FOR OTHER
FORMS OF SENIOR HOUSING.
PROJECT WE ASK YOUR I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BETTER NOW
ANOTHER EXCELLENT CONCURRENT
SPEECH. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS ALSO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO ASSUME LIMITS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY NINE.
WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY ONE
SIXTY ONE SIXTY ONE AND ONE
SIXTY TWO AND THEN A FEW MORE
AFTER THAT. FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
NINE IS SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI
ON SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY TWO.
SIR WHY CASKEY IS READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI AN ACT RELATING
TO CONTRACTS CENTER KELSEY I
MISS PERSON SIMPLY AMENDMENTS
SIMPLY REQUIRED THAT ANY
TIMELINE REQUIREMENTS CONTAINED
AN ARBITRATION AGREEMENTS ARE
REASONABLE THE BILL IN CHIEF SB
SEVEN SIXTY TO ADD TRANSPARENCY
AROUND THE DUTY OF ARBITRATION
FEES IN ORDER TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY DELAYS. IN THE
RESOLUTION OF DISPUTES FOR
WORKERS AND CONSUMERS IN
ARBITRATION AND I REJECT VIRGIN
I'VE A SENIOR WHITE HOUSE HE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HE MET
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS ALSO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY.
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SO NONE I THIRTY
NINE WHO KNOWS IS LIMITS ARE
CONCURRED IN OR MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY. SENATOR ACTIONS
ON S. B. NINE SENATOR ATKINS IS
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL NINE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. INTERACTIONS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT OH HOW I WISH I
COULD- GET THE CONCURRENT SO
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON- JUST YET BUT- WITH
FAT R. SENATE BILL NINE IS BACK
BEFORE US TODAY ON CONCURRENCE.
MONTHS OF HARD WORK BY SO MANY
PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM AND SO MANY
OTHERS WENT INTO THIS MOMENT
BEFORE TALKING ABOUT THE BILL I
WANT TO PAUSE FOR A MINUTE TO
JUST SAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE DEDICATION FOR THE
TOUGH CONVERSATIONS FOR THE
COURAGE TO SUPPORT A SOLUTION
THAT WILL HELP MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN OUR STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS. THIS IS A BILL
THAT PROVIDES OPTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS BY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS FOR THEM TO CREATE A
DUPLEX OR SUBDIVIDE AN EXISTING
LOT IN SINGLE FAMILY ZONES UP
TO FOUR UNITS. I WANT TO
DISCUSS SOME IMPORTANT
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL THAT
WERE ADDED WHILE IT WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY EARLIER THIS MONTH I
ADDED AN AMENDMENT THAT
STRENGTHENS THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
PROVISION BY MAKING IT A
STATEWIDE REQUIREMENT. TO
ENSURE THAT HOMEOWNERS BENEFIT
FROM THESE NEW HOUSING OPTIONS
NOT CORPORATE INVESTORS. THE
INTENT IS SIMPLE WE WANT TO
PREVENT SPECULATION AND
GENTRIFICATION IN ADDITION SP
NINE NOW AUTHORIZES A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO DENY A PROPOSED
HOUSING PROJECT OR LOT SPLIT IF
BUILDING OFFICIAL FINDS THAT
THERE WOULD BE AN ADVERSE
IMPACT ON PUBLIC HEALTH OR
SAFETY. OR THE PHYSICAL
ENVIRONMENT THAT CANNOT BE
MITIGATED FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN DOCUMENT A
SPECIFIC FIRE HAZARD FOR A
PARTICULAR PROJECT THEY COULD
DENY IT IF THERE IS NO WAY TO
AVOID THE EFFECT OF THE PROJECT.
THIS AN IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THAT S. NINE STRIKES AN
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
RESPECTING THE LOCAL CONTROL.
AND CREATING THE ENVIRONMENT
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
HOUSING OPTIONS WE NEED THOSE
OPTIONS MORE THAN EVER TO HELP
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE. S. B. NINE IS THE
CULMINATION OF YEARS OF HARD
WORK AND COLLABORATION BY MANY
ESPECIALLY ITS CO AUTHORS MY
COLLEAGUES FROM SALINAS SAN
JOSE LONG BEACH BALDWIN PARK
SAN FRANCISCO. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST MY COLLEAGUE FROM
HEALDSBURG. THE REMAINING
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE HOUSING
LEAD GROUP OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
LOS ANGELES RIVERSIDE AND
BERKELEY ALSO SHOULD BE
COMMENDED FOR THEIR CONTINUED
EFFORTS TO HELPING SOLVE
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS. A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS WHO
CHAMPION THIS BILL IN THE
ASSEMBLY ALONG WITH SPEAKER
RENDON. COLLEAGUES I KNOW SOME
OF YOU HAVE HEARD ME SAY THIS
BUT IT BEARS REPEATING ON THIS
FLOOR. THIS BILL CAN HELP MAKE
THAT DREAM OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
POSSIBLE. THIS BILL STANDS TO
HELP MAKE COMMUNITIES MORE
INCLUSIVE. AND IT STANDS TO SET
THE STATE UP ON A PATH WHERE
THERE ARE MORE HOUSING OPTIONS
MORE SUPPLY AND MORE ACCESS TO
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. SINGER ACTOR
CAN SWITCH LIKE TO CLOSE- I'M
SORRY I'M SORRY SECONDS HANG ON
ONE SECOND SENATE RATES YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MOM MR
PRESIDENT A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR AND I BELIEVE I POSE
THIS TO- THE GOOD SENATOR FROM-
FROM HIM FROM SAN DIEGO AND WE
CAN'T WHEN IT CAME THROUGH THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE AND THAT IS
WHETHER IT'S A FAX. OF THE H.
AWAY IS A COMMUNITY- INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS AND WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THAT IS ACTUALLY PART OF THE
RECORD. AND CAN IT BE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT IS A MAJOR CONCERN
FOR A LOT OF THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN RESET. LET
ME THE MASS INTERACTIONS OF
SHOVELING TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS CENTER SECONDS YES OF
COURSE OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
AGAIN ARE WE HAVE MANY
COMMUNITIES AND- YOU KNOW
ORANGE COUNTY THAT WERE
REQUIRED TO SET UP A HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES- TO COVER THE COST OF
THE MUNICIPAL- MAINTENANCE
BECAUSE THE COUNTY WAS NOT ABLE
TO DO IT AT THAT TIME SO. THE
QUESTION IS COULD YOU REPEAT
FOR THE RECORD WHETHER OR NOT
THIS INCLUDES OUR EXCLUSIVE OF
COMMUNITY INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
AND HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATIONS WITH
CC IN OURS. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR- FOR THE QUESTION- AND- HI
AS WE'VE INDICATED ON THE
RECORD HERE CERTAINLY- WHEN IT
WAS ON THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE
BEFORE. FIVE IT IS SILENT ON
THE ISSUE MEETING THE BILL
CONTAINS NO PROVISIONS WOULD
SUPERSEDES AN H. AWAY OR CID
GOVERNING DOCUMENT- AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH OTHER HOUSING
LEGISLATION SB NINE WOULD HAVE
TO CONTAIN EXPLICIT AND
PROACTIVE PROVISION TO OVERRIDE
HOAS AND SEE ID'S THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT. SP NOT PROJECTS
FURTHER- THERE WILL BE A LETTER
TO THE JOURNAL- TO FURTHER PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD- SO THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR GIVING
ME THE CHANCE TO RESPOND. SERIK
INSTINCT YOU CENTER BASED. WITH
YOU I SPRAY MY HERE LET ME
OPPOSE I HAVE. ON PIECE. OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS- THAT KIND
OF. MOST OF THE CITIES THAT WE
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES SITTING ON
THIS FOR. A WHILE BEING
CONTACTED AND ANSWER SPECIFIC
ARGUMENTS. ARE TOO THESE ARE.
PARTICULAR HOUSING BILLS AGAIN
OR THEY HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
PARKING ISSUES AND I KNOW
THERE'S SOME. RATHER LOOSE OUR
RESTRICTIONS I WOULD CONSIDER
THEM LOSE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
SPECIFIC FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
IN TERMS OF- PROHIBITING AID.
ON THE- CONSTRUCTION OF A
PROBLEM THAN EIGHTY U. OR
DUPLEX. FIVE BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT IN TRANSIT RICH AREAS BUT
STILL. THOSE WILL BE BATTLES
THAT ARE FOUGHT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. AND CREATE CHAOS IN
CERTAINLY- THESE ARE THINGS
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO DO SO. I WILL REMAIN
OPPOSED TO HANDLE JUST NOTE
AGAIN. THERE ARE FOUR PAGES
SINGLE SPACED HERE. OF THE
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS THE
CITY'S REPRESENTED BY CITY
COUNCILS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE RAISED
OPPOSITION ON THESE VERY POINTS
THAT CONTINUE TO BE IGNORED. HI.
G. STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES IS THERE ANY
OTHER DISK OR THE ON ITEM.
SANDERS CAN. MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- I STAND STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I KNOW THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN VARIOUS CLAIMS ABOUT
THAT WE ARE GOING TO ADD TO OUR
FIRE CRISIS DUE TO THIS BUT AS
THE AUTHOR JUST DESCRIBED THE-
WHAT WAS BUILT INTO THE BILL TO
DEAL WITH THAT FOR THOSE THAT-
THOSE- HOUSING UNITS IN OUR
MOVIES AND I THINK THAT YES
CLEARLY OUR STATE IS A HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONE HOWEVER OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IS KILLING AT
LEAST AS MANY PEOPLE AS OUR
FIRES WITH THE- THE LEVEL OF
HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE. AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING DRIVEN
OUT OF OUR STATE BECAUSE OF THE
COST OF HOUSING AND THIS IS
JUST ONE OF MANY ACTIONS WE
NEED TO TAKE TO ADDRESS IT AND
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU SENT SENATOR SKINNER
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO STAND
HERE ALSO STRONG SUPPORT IN A
PROPER CLOTH- AND I WANTED TO
SHARE THAT- I'VE BEEN HERE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW AND I THINK
THAT THIS BILL. HAS BEEN ONE OF
THE MOST AWFUL CONSENSUS
BUILDING BILLS THAT I'VE SEEN
SO FAR I REALLY DID BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER FROM DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. TO REALLY
ANALYZE THE NEEDS AND HAS A
LOCAL. FORMER COUNCILMEMBER I
KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
CONCERNS WITH THEIR LOCAL
COUNCIL MEMBERS BUT- I WANT
EVERYONE TO BE REST ASSURED
THAT IT WAS THOUGHTFUL. WE
BROUGHT ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
TABLE WE TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. EVERYTHING THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP. AND I THINK
THAT THIS WAS A GOOD BALANCE OF
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND AND TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS. BUT AT THE END
WE DO NEED HOUSING AND SO I
START HAVING STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CENTER SECONDS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MR PRESIDENT
THANK YOU AND I AGAIN I'M JUST
GONNA SAY THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES. THIS HAS OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS BEEN ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND DIALOGUE. AND
SO OFTEN WE FIND THAT WE CANNOT
ALL COME TO CONSENSUS ON
SOMETHING THIS WAS NOT AN EASY
PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO DO. AND
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES KNOW VERY
WELL THAT THIS HAS TRAVELED A
LONG ROAD WITH MANY AMENDMENTS.
WITH MANY- DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
HOW TO BALANCE AND SUPPORT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND AT THE
SAME TIME. AKE CARE OF THE
BROADEST ISSUE THAT FACES OUR
STATE ONE OF THE BROADEST IT'S
NOT THE ONLY OF COURSE WE HAVE
OTHER CRITICAL ISSUES. BUT THE
LACK OF HOUSING STOCK THE LACK
OF HOUSING THAT IS AFFORDABLE.
HELLO THE LACK OF HOUSING THAT
IS AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE TO
ACTUALLY OWN A HOME IN THIS
GREAT STATE HAS BEEN A
DISCUSSION. I KNOW THAT
REASONABLE MINDS CAN DISAGREE I
AM INCREDIBLY PROUD OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE BROUGHT ON
BOARD. MANY WITH CONDITIONS AND
DIALOGUE AND CHANGES. TO THIS
BILL. I AM PROUD OF THE WORK
EFFORT EFFORT I AM PROUD OF THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SUPPORTED IT I
HAVE LISTENED. I AS A FORMER
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER MYSELF I
HAVE LISTENED- TO THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CONCERNS I UNDERSTAND
THE FEARS. BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE FIND A
WAY TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE OF HOUSING PRODUCTION AND
AFFORDABILITY. COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA FIVE AT KINS ARI
FAITH NO BACKER FIVE FORGES NO
BRADFORD I CAN'T BUY A- I
COURTESY HI DALLY. FIVE DOT I
TORONTO HI EGGMAN EYE LASER NO
GUNS ALLAH'S HIGH GROWTH RD
HURTS BURKE. I WAS SO. FIVE FOR
TIDO FIVE JONES NO CAN LONGER.
LAYERED HI LLEVA FIVE THE MON.
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN BY A SHOW VOGUE
NO TEN FIVE FOURTEEN TINA HI
RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE
STERN AMBERG I BY CASKEY I
WINNER I WILL. NOW PLEASE CALL
THE APRS MEMBERS. ALAN CAN
LONGER. THE MON. NEWMAN STERN.
SIZE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS SEVEN A
SIM LIMITS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO THE
FINAL ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE S. B.
THREE THIRTY ONE SENATOR LEYVA
ISRAELIS SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR LEYVA AN ACT RELATING
TO CIVIL ACTIONS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BILL
THREE THREE ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE SP THREE THREE ONE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE SILENCE NO
MORE ACT EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITION ON NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS NDAS. TO NOW COVER
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS INVOLVING
ALL FORMS OF HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION. THIS BILL ALSO
EXPANDS THE PROHIBITION ON
OVERLY BROAD CONFIDENTIALITY
AND NON DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES
IN EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENTS TO
COVER WORKERS WHO ARE REQUIRED
TO SIGN THESE TYPES OF CLAUSES.
AS PART OF A SEVERANCE
AGREEMENT. RECENT AMENDMENTS
CLARIFIED THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
RETROACTIVE AND THAT IS
SEVERANCE AMOUNT MAY BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS THE CALCHAMBER HAS
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION AND IS
NOW NEUTRAL ON THE BILL. SIMPLY
PUT SP THREE THREE ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT WORKERS KNOW THAT
THEY CAN SPEAK OUT ABOUT
UNLAWFUL CONDUCT AND THAT THEY
CANNOT BE SUED FOR TALKING
ABOUT UNLAWFUL CONDUCT MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THE CASHIER LIVE IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE. SET A
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE
HE'S HERE LATER- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I. AT TEN FIVE
EIGHTHS NO BACKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I CALLED BETA HI
CORTESE I DALLY. NO DODD FIVE
THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER.
FIVE CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG HI WAS SO HYPER TANTO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA I LIVE ALONE.
HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MEN I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO CONTROL OF
BOTH KNOW PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE
STERNE AMBERG I LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND MEMBERS WERE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
TWO S. B. FOUR NINETY SEVEN
SENATOR RAMON. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LAMONT AN ACT
RELATING TO DIRECT DEPOSIT OF
FUNDS CENTER LIMB THANK YOU THE
SENATE BILL FOUR NINETY SEVEN
IS BACK IN CONCURRENCE WITH
MINOR AND TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THE BILL CLOSED A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS NON BANK ENTITIES FROM
EVADING CALIFORNIAN FEDERAL
LAWS BY CHARGING OVERDRAFT FEES
ON ACCOUNTS FOR INDIVIDUALS
RECEIVING PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION STATE
DISABILITY OR CHILD SUPPORT.
PAYMENTS DISTRIBUTED BY THE
STATE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION IT HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU CENTER THE
MONETARY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO. SEEING NO
OBJECTION HIGHS THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO A SIMILAR AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS OF
MOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
THREE SENATOR WILK ON SP. FIVE
OH NINE. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH NINE BY
SENATOR WEALTH AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALING ARTS AND DECLARING
THE URGENCY THERE OF CITRIX
MEDIALLY CENTER WORK THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS BEFORE YOU
TODAY IS SP FIVE OH NINE. WHICH
CREATES A TEMPORARY LICENSE FOR
GRADUATING OPTOMETRY STUDENTS
WHO CANNOT TRAVEL TO NORTH
CAROLINA TO TAKE THE FINAL PART
OF THE REQUIRED EXAMINATION.
DUE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THIS BILL RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS BACK
IN THE SENATE CONCURRENCE. THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WERE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE AND RESPECTFULLY ASKS
FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WELCOME THE DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS ITEM ALSO QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY
NINE KNOWS IS ZERO ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NUMBERS WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AND THEN BACK TO ONE
SIXTY FIVE. MOVING ON TO ONE
SIXTY SIX CENTER ALONE ON SB
SEVEN SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR LYNN MON AND AFTER
RELATING TO SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS CERTAINLY. THANK YOU SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SP FIVE SEVEN FIVE
SEVEN HOLD SOLAR INSTALLATION
CONTRACTS TO THE SAME STANDARDS
AS OTHER HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACTOR ASSEMBLYMAN
MINCEMEAT TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THIS BILL
PASSED THE SENATE UNANIMOUSLY
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NEVER.
THANK YOU CEREMONY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
FILE AND I'M ONE SIXTY SIX.
SEEING NONE EYES THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZEROS. A SIMILAR
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ONE SIXTY EIGHT. WE
HAVE US BRADFORD ON SENATE BILL
H. TWENTY SEVEN. READ FOR A
RING. PASS ISRAELI SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN BY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY
CENTER BRETT THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS B. EIGHT TO SEVEN
AS THE PUBLIC SAFETY OMNIBUS
BILL SMPLY BLACK CONCURRENCE
THE MOMENT SIMPLY DELETE ONE
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE
BUDGET AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS ITEM ALSO QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO A SIM LIM
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. STAND BY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE
SENATOR JONES MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR JONES AND
ACTOR RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES AND OCCURRING THERE TO
SEE THEIR UPTAKE FIXED
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR JONES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATE BILL
FIVE FORTY NINE REQUIRES SOCIAL
WORKERS WHO WERE DECLARED
ESSENTIAL WORKERS SHOULD
RECEIVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
HEALTH AND SAFETY EQUIPMENT. AS
OTHER SOCIAL WORKERS A SIMILAR
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING I ASK FOR YOUR I
BOATS THANK YOU SENATOR JONES
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
THEM. FIVE THREE NINE NINE ZERO
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM TWO OH ONE TWO A
ONE TO TWO OR THREE TWO OR NINE
TO EIGHTEEN AND THEN SEVERAL
DOZEN OF FOLLOW AFTER THAT SO
IF WE CAN CAN MOVE ON TO FILE
I'M- TWO OH ONE. CENTER COM
LOGGER IS BEING RECOGNIZED AND
SHE IS READY SECRETARY PLEASE
RE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE
AN ACT RELATING TO TAXATION.
CENTER COME ON THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE OH THREE IT
IS A DISTRICT BILL SPONSORED BY
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES THAT
WILL ENABLE TAXPAYERS TO
DISPUTE PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS.
IN A TIMELIER MANNER
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND THE POOL OF POTENTIAL
APPLICANTS FOR SERVICE ON AN
ASSESSMENT APPEALS BOARD IN LA
COUNTY. ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD
PERMIT THE LA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO REDUCE THE THREE
YEAR WAITING PERIOD WHICH
FORMER ASSESSOR EMPLOYEES ARE
SUBJECT TO BEFORE BECOMING
ELIGIBLE TO SERVE. ON AN
APPEALS BOARD TO NO LESS THAN
ONE YEAR THE COUNTY IS FACING A
CASELOAD OF OVER FORTY THOUSAND
APPEALS A TOTAL THAT WAS
EXACERBATED BY THE CLOSURES
BROUGHT ON BY THE PANDEMIC. IN
THE BACKLOG IS EXPECTED TO KEEP
TRENDING UPWARD WITH MANY
RETAILERS EXPECTED TO FILE DUE
TO A PANDEMIC FEEL DECLINE IN
PROPERTY VALUES THIS MEASURE
BUILDS UPON EFFORTS FROM LAST
SESSION WHERE WE RECOGNIZE THE
NEED TO INCREASE THE CAPACITY
OF THE BOARD. TO ADDRESS
INCREASING WORKLOADS AND PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT REMOVES THE
CAP IN STATE LAW ON THE NUMBER
OF ASSESSMENT APPEAL BOARDS IN
A COUNTY. THIS IS A LOW COST
STRAIGHT FORWARD AND NECESSARY
MEASURES THAT WILL HELP THE
COUNTY SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
THE TIME IN WHICH TAXPAYERS
APPEALS ARE HEARD IT IS
SUPPORTED. BY THE LA COUNTY
ASSESSOR JEFFREY PRANG THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR COME OUR-
CALLER ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WITH FALLON I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I BASE. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DALLY NO DOG HI
TORONTO HI A COMMON. I GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES I GROSS.
HERTZBERG FIVE WITH SO I HER
TADO I JONES NO CAMCORDER I
LAYERED I LABOR. HI THE MOON.
FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MEN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. BUT
HELLO FOLKS I CAN I FOURTEEN
ZERO. I BROUGHT HI PREVIA HI
SKINNER I STERN AMBERG HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL. NO
THIS CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
FACE NO FORGES. GROVE NIELSEN.
GROVE NO NIELSEN. STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY ONE KNOWS SIX MAJOR
PASSES WERE MOVING ON TO FIGHT
HIM TO- THREE SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOR SOME THE MEMBER MAZE
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SOMEBODY
FELL FOR TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAZE AT AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CENTERS FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR PRESIDENT- THIS BILL. WOULD
REQUIRE- WHERE TERM LIMITS ARE
IMPOSED. TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
NO FEWER THAN TWO TERMS FOR
COUNTY SUPERVISORS ARE-
SPECIFIES THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. INCLUDED THE
DEFINITION OF COUNTY OFFICERS
FOR WHOM THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REQUIRED TO
PRESCRIBE COMPENSATION THE BILL
WOULD SPECIFICALLY SPECIFY TO
ME WOULD SPECIFY. THAT YOU
WOULD NOT AFFECT ANY TERM
LIMITS THAT WERE LEGALLY IN
EFFECT PRIOR TO JANUARY. ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN ANY COUNTY
S. RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR GORGEOUS.
PRESIDENT. WHEN I WAS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I
TRY TO PUT FORWARD. TERM
LIMITS. AT THE TIME I THOUGHT
THAT. THREE TERMS WHICH WOULD
BE A TOTAL OF FOUR YEARS- FOR-
YOUR TERM SENSE THREE B. TOTAL
TWELVE YEARS WOULD BE A
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF TIMETO DO
THE PEOPLE'S WORK AND SO I
THINK THERE IS A BALANCE
BETWEEN TERM LIMITS THAT ARE
PUNITIVE. AND TERM LIMITS THAT
I THINK ARE EFFECTIVE WHILE
STILL ENCOURAGING GOOD PEOPLE
TO LEARN AND BECOME MORE
EFFECTIVE AS TIME GOES ON. THE
IDEA OF HAVING ONE TERM. THIS
IS A TOUGH ISSUE FOR ME MORE
FROM A PHILOSOPHICAL STANDPOINT
WHERE YOU WANT TO RESPECT. THE
WILL OF THE LOCAL CONSTITUENCY
THE LOCAL ELECTORATE THAT VOTED
IN THIS WAY. BUT IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE THE EFFICACY OF AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WOULD
FUNCTION. EFFECTIVELY BY
LIMITING IT TO A SINGLE TERM. I
THINK WE HAVE SEEN IT
EXPERIMENTATION IS ACROSS THE
STATE AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND I THINK ONE TERM IS JUST
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH TO DO THE
PEOPLE'S BUSINESS AND EXPECT
INDIVIDUALS- TO BE ABLE TO
LEARN THE INSTRUMENTALITY IN
THE FUNCTIONALITY OF
GOVERNMENT. AND IT'S HARD WHEN
THE LOCAL ELECTORATE ONE CITY
IN ONE SPECIFIC WAY BY VIRTUE
OF A BALLOT INITIATIVE. BUT IT
ALL ENDS THE OVERALL
EFFECTIVENESS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS I RESPECT BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE. I WOULD
HAVE TO- CONFIRM MY SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE YOU JUST
SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW GOVERNMENT
TO FUNCTION. WITH THAT LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME IN SERVICE.
THANK YOU SIR BARGES CENTER
GROVE. THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT HOW WAS IT GONNA RISE
AND SPEAK AGAINST THIS BILL
INTO MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
BROUGHT IT UP AND THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT MEASURE K. PASSED
BY DECEMBER TO DINO CITIZENS
THAT VOTED. TO DO SUPERVISOR-
LIMITS TERM LIMITS AND ALSO
SALARIES THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS DIDN'T LIKE THAT
AND THEY FILED A LAWSUIT BUT
THEY LOST AND- SO NOW THIS
BILL'S GOING TO THE BUILDING TO
CIRCUMVENT AGAIN THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE. THE PEOPLE OF SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY HAVE MADE
THEIR VOICE CLEAR THAT THEY
WANT TO LIMIT TERM LIMITS FOR
SUPERVISORS AND- THE SALARIES
SORRY RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. SENATOR LEVIN. THANK OU
I MISS PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AS YOU
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE SAY MAJOR K.
WAS PUT ON THE BALLOT I DON'T
LIKE MAJOR K. I DIDN'T LIKE
MAJOR K. THERE WAS A COMPETING
BALLOT MEASURE MEASURE H. WHICH
I SUPPORTED AND WORKED FOR BUT
MAJOR K. PAST I THINK THAT IT
HARMS THE COUNTY SUPERVISORS IN
MY COUNTY OF SAMBAR DINO BY
LIMITING A TERM LIMITS TO ONE
TERM LIMIT. NO BENEFITS NO
PENSION SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR I THINK WE'LL HAVE A
ROTATING GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO
WILL NEVER REALLY FULLY DO THE
JOB OF THE PEOPLE IN SEMINOLE
COUNTY BUT THAT DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER WHAT MATTERS IS THAT THE
PEOPLE OF SAN MARINO COUNTY
VOTED TO UPHOLD MEASURE KAY AND
IS NOT OUR JOB TO OVERTURN THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE IT REMINDS
ME A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN GEORGIA. WELL
DON'T LIKE THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
VOTED IN GEORGIA SO THEY'RE
CHANGING THE LAWS THAT WILL
MAKE IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
VOTE IT IS NOT OUR JOB HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. TO DO AS I SAID IN
COMMITTEE A WORKAROUND OF WHAT
THE CITIZENS WANT SO I RISE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION WE DO HAVE A
PROPOSITION PROBLEM HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
OVERLY USED. BUT WHEN PEOPLE
VOTE THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
THANK YOU CENTER LABOR SENATOR
ROTH. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
JUST PERHAPS A GROWING FASTER
WE DON'T ASK QUESTIONS BUT LET
ME ASK A QUESTION OF THE FOUR
JACKIE DOES THIS THING HURTS
BERG WOULD YOU TAKE A QUESTION
COURSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
CETERA DOES THIS- DOES THIS
MEASURE IMPACT THE ACTION THAT
WAS TAKEN BY THE VOTERS. OF
SAMBAR DINO COUNTY THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE NOW. SO THIS
WOULD ONLY IMPACT. SITUATIONS
IN OTHER COUNTIES WHERE
CONSTITUENTS OR VOTERS MIGHT
CHOOSE TO PUT ONE OF THESE
MEASURES ON THE BALLOT THIS
MEASURE WAS AMENDED SENATOR IT
SAYS SPECIFICALLY ON PAGE TWO
LINES TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY FOUR
THE CHANGES MADE TO THE
SUBDIVISION BY THIS ACT. THAT
ADDED THIS PARAGRAPH SHALL NOT
AFFECT ANY TERM LIMITS THAT WE
LEGALLY AFFECT CARTER JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
RESPECT TO THE MEASURES WE
COUNTED IT WOULD DISCUSS THE
SPELL IS BEEN SPECIFICALLY
AMENDED SO AS TO NOT AFFECT THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE AS WAS
EXPRESSED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. PLEASE ENTER THE
CENTER UP ANY OTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THE-
LABOR- IF I MAY- BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ONLY FIXED
TERM LIMITS IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T AFFECT HEY OR ANY OF
THOSE ISSUES. YEAH THE LANGUAGE
SAYS I DON'T GOOD QUESTION DID
THE LANGUAGE SAYS TERM LIMITS
SHOWED THEY WERE LEGALLY IN
EFFECT PRIOR TO JANUARY ONE SO
DOES NOT EXPRESS ANY OTHER.
RESTRICTIVE MEASURE AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THAT I DON'T
MISS U. K. LIMITED SALARY AND
OTHER THINGS LIKE PROP ONE
FORTY DID WITH RESPECT TO THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. BUT THE POINT
IS THAT- THE KEY THING IS THIS
ONLY DEALS WITH TERM LIMITS IT
ONLY TALKS ABOUT TERM LIMITS
AND I DON'T THINK IN ANY WAY
WITH OTHERWISE AFFECT ANYTHING
ELSE THAT THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS MIGHT OTHERWISE DONE. IS
NOT ADDRESSED CORRECTLY SINCE
EIGHTY EIGHT SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT FOLKS KNOW
IT'S AFFECTING TERM LIMITS THE
ONLY OTHER ONLY BUT THE OTHER
THINGS THAT MAJOR K. DID COULD
BE CHANGED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR LEYVA ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE OR
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR. ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR. DEBATE
CENTER GORGEOUS. I APOLOGIZE
FOR RISING TWICE- I WANT TO
FOLLOW UP ON THE- THE QUESTION
POSED BY THE SENATOR FROM
RIVERSIDE. SO THE WAY THAT THIS
BILL JUST BECAUSE WE COULD
ROUTE WE CAN REITERATE-
QUESTION POSED BY THE CENTER
FOR RIVER CENTER FOR JUST OUR
U. S. NOT THE AUTHOR QUESTION.
IF- VISUALLY YES. CENTER IF I
MADE THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT'S IF THE- FLOOR
SPONSOR WILL ACCEPT IT OF
COURSE IF YOU GET TO THE
QUESTION WE HAVE TO HAVE. MY
NEVER ENDING IS IF YOU COULD
RECITE. YOUR EXPLANATION YOU
GAVE JUST A MOMENT AGO. THIS
BILL DOES NOT RETROACTIVELY ON
DO. THE VOTE THAT WAS ON THAT
WAS CONDUCTED BEFORE IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT AND I
DID NOT GIVE YOU AN EXPLANATION
I READ YOU THE TEXT OF THE
MEASURE. AND THE SPECIFIC DATES
FOR SO SOLID PINION IS THE
WORDS OF THE MEASURE. CENTER
BARGES ON YOUR OWN AND YOU.
KNOW THAT SATISFIES. THANK YOU
SAM BURGESS ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTERS
FOR IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I. THANK
YOU SINNERS BERG SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA. ATKINS I FACE NO
BACKER HI PORGES HI BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI PROTESTING I DALLY NO
DODD FIVE TORONTO I A COMMON. I
GLAZER FIVE DOLLARS HI GROVE NO
HERTZBERG FIVE WITH SO HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED I LLEVA NO THE MON.
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN NO
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NOPE A CHOKE
HI PAM. FORTINO I. ROSS HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI STERN- BERG
HI BY KELSEY FIVE WINNER FIVE
WELL I. PLEASE CALL THE APRS
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA I. HER TADO.
THE MON. CAN I STERN. HIGHS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FILE AN M. TWO OH NINE.
WHICH WILL BE FOLLOWED BY TWO
EIGHTEEN AND THEN TO TWENTY
THREE SO TWO OH NINE WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP RIGHT NOW-
SENATOR HUESO FOR CINEMA RAY IS
ON AJ ARE SIXTEEN. SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAZ RELATIVE TO
IMMIGRATION THERE WAS A- THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS TODAY
I PRESENT EACH YEAR SIXTEEN ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLING A MAJORITY
LEADER RADIUS WHICH CALLS ON
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
THE BIDEN HIGHER HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION TO PASS
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. FOR THE ELEVEN MILLION
IMMIGRANTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY
WERE HALF OF THE CHILDREN IN
THE STATE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
IMMIGRANT PARENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE FEAR OF
DEPORTATION AND FAMILY
SEPARATION IS A DAILY REALITY
FOR MANY OF OUR IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES. THIS ARGUE THIS THE
DEBATE ON IMMIGRATION REFORM
HAS BEEN TAKING PLACE FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. AND YET NO ACTION
ON BEHALF OF OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BRING SOME
SENSIBLE PATHWAY FOR IMMIGRANTS
LIVING THE UNITED STATES TO
BECOME CITIZENS OF THIS GREAT
NATION THERE'S NO BETTER TIME
THAN NOW TO PENCIL SENSIBLE
IMMIGRATION REFORM FOR FOLKS.
WHO ARE HERE EVERY DAY
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR ECONOMY
PART OF OUR COMMUNITY IN SO
MANY INEXTRICABLE WAYS AND I
ASK YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT. UP
THIS RESOLUTION CALLING IN OUR
ON OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ACT. THANK YOU SENT AWAY SO IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI
BASED. BACKER I PORCHES HI
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI COURTESY.
DALLY GOD HI TORONTO I ADNAN HI
PLEASE SIR FIVE DOLLARS HI
GROSS. HERTZBERG I WAS SO HYPER
TANTO I JONES. CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LLEVA I THE MON HI
THE WIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT YOUR VOTE
I CAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH
I REVIEW I SKINNER. HI STERN
BERGER HI LIKE HOW SKI FIVE
WINNER FIVE WELL I. PLEASE CALL
THE OFFICE AND MEMBERS. BAIT.
CORTESE I DALLY. GROWTH JONES.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR
A MOMENTWE WANT TO RECOGNIZE A
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS BODY
SENATOR JACK SCOTT IS UP IN THE
GALLERY IF WE CAN GIVE SENATOR
SCOTT AND APPROPRIATE TO
GREETING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. SENATOR SCOTT
WELCOME HOME WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE.
RENDERED PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO A FILE AND.
TWO TWENTY THREE. CAN WE HAVE
SENATOR SKINNER FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS I'M SORRY
I'M SORRY. STAND BY I SKIPPED
ONE. ELEVEN TO EIGHTEEN. PHYLON
TO EIGHTEEN CENTER WINNER FOR A
SUMMER BARNHART AT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURNER **** BATH AN ACT
RELATING TO VEHICLES CENTER
WINNER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
BECAUSE I'M PRESENTING A B. ONE
TWENTY TWO ON BEHALF OF A
SUMMER MEMBER BURNER FOR ABOUT-
THIS LEGISLATION WILL MAKE
INTERSECTIONS SAFER FOR
BICYCLISTS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS. BY ALLOWING BY-
BICYCLISTS TO TREAT STOP SIGNS
AS YIELD SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING
AN INTERSECTION VEHICLE CODE
TWO ONE ZERO FOUR ALREADY
PROVIDES A CLEAR LEGAL
DEFINITION AND EXPECTATION FOR
THOSE WHO ARE REQUIRED TO YIELD
AT AN INTERSECTION THIS IS NOT
A NEW CONCEPT UNDER THIS NEW
PROVISION- THE DRIVER OF ANY-VEHICLE- INCLUDING BIKES-
APPROACHING CITY UNDER THIS
EXISTING SECTION THE DRIVER OF
ANY VEHICLE INCLUDING A BIKER
APPROACHES AN INTERSECTION WITH
A YIELD SIGN. MUST YIELD THE
RIGHT OF WAY TO ANY VEHICLES OR
PEDESTRIANS THAT HAVE ALREADY
ENTERED THE INTERSECTION MAYBE
ONE TWENTY TWO USES THIS COMMON
UNDERSTANDING OF A YIELD SIGN
TO ALLOW BIKE RIDERS
APPROACHING AN INTERSECTION
WITH A STOP SIGN NOT A STOP
LIGHT ONLY A STOP SIGN TO SLOW
DOWN AND YIELD TO ANY CARS AND
BE I'M PRODUCTIONS ALREADY AT
THE INTERSECTION. I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT EIGHTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IS NOT A BILL TO AUTHORIZE
CYCLISTS TO DO WHAT IS
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS A
ROLLING STOP SIGN ROLLING STOP
SIGN IS A LEGAL NOW AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ILLEGAL UNDER
THIS BELT- ROLLING STOP SIGN IS
NOT YIELDING ONLY YIELDING IS
ALLOWED UNDER THE SPELL-
YIELDING- HOW DOES OFFER
SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS. FOR
CYCLISTS THIS PROCESS IS
INTUITIVE BECAUSE IT FITS WITH
OUR EVERYDAY RIDING EXPERIENCE
AND ALLOWS FORWARD MOMENTUM TO
BE MAINTAINED FOR DRIVERS THIS
ADJUSTMENT OFFERS- DECREASE
TIME OF EXPOSURE TO THE CYCLIST
CYCLISTS WILL NOT WILL MOVE.
MORE QUICKLY- AND EXPEDITIOUSLY
IN THE INTERSECTION- AND
CREATES A POTENTIAL FOR FEWER-
TRAFFIC COLLISION. BUT
DIFFERENT STATES ALREADY HAVE-
THIS PROVISION ON DELAWARE FOR
EXAMPLE ADOPTED A STOP AS
YOU'LL LAWS FOR CYCLISTS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ACCORDING TO
THE DELAWARE STATE POLICE-
CRASHES INVOLVING SUCH-
BICYCLES SPECIFICALLY AT A STOP
SIGN CONTROLLED INTERSECTIONS
FELL BY 23% IN THE THIRTY
MONTHS AFTER THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED BY A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION INTO LAW- UTAH
IDAHO COLORADO ARKANSAS
WASHINGTON NORTH DAKOTA AND
OREGON HAVE ADOPTED SIMILAR
LAWS- WHETHER CALIFORNIANS RIDE
FOR RECREATION. AS PART OF
SUSTAINABLE LIFESTYLE CHOICES
ARE BECAUSE IT'S THEIR ONLY
TRANSPORTATION OPTION EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND ENSURE IS
THAT CYCLISTS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS ARE SAFER AT
INTERSECTIONS. WITH A STOP SIGN
OF RESPECT WELLS FARGO. THANK
YOU CENTER WINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISK OR DEBATE OR DEBATE ON
FILE INTO EIGHTEEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY TWO. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS I FACE.
BACKER FIVE PORGES NO BRADFORD
I KERR BY ADAM. CORTEZ. THREE
HI DALLY NO DODD I THERE ARE SO
HI EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER. I
CONSOLIDATE I GROSS. HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO FIVE
JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LIVE ON I THE MOON. HI MCGUIRE
I MELINDA'S NO BEEN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO
PAN HI FOURTEEN TINA HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WINNER. HI WELL I THIS CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS. BASED CABRERA.
GROVE I JONES. STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE MEASURE
PASSES NOW WE'RE GOING ON A TWO
TWENTY THREE MEMBERS OF WHICH
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY TWO TWENTY
SIX AND TWO TWENTY EIGHT TO
TWENTY THREE IS SENATOR SCANNER
FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL WITH FIVE EIGHTEEN BY SOME
A MEMBER WICKS AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMINAL LAW. CENTERS THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED A LAW THAT
TOOK AWAY A JUDGE'S SENTENCING
DISCRETION WHEN A DEFENDANT
CAME BEFORE THEM ACCUSED OF
MULTIPLE OFFENSES DURING A
SINGLE ACT. THIS REMOVE THE
DISCRETION THAT JUDGES
PREVIOUSLY HAD TO CHARGE THE
DEFENDANT WITH THE SENTENCE
THAT THE JUDGE DEEMED MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE EVIDENCE
THAT WAS PRESENTED TO THE COURT.
PROVIDING COURTS THE ABILITY TO
WEIGH THE CONTEXT OF THE CRIME
THE HISTORY OF THE OFFENDER IN
THE OTHER FACTORS PRESENTED IN
THE COURT GIVES THE JUDGE THE
ABILITY TO SENSE FAIRLY. AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN RESTORES THE
DISCRETION THAT JUDGES
PREVIOUSLY HAD WHEN DETERMINING
THE SENTENCE FOR AN ACT
PUNISHABLE IN DIFFERENT WAYS BY
DIFFERENT PROVISIONS OF THE
LAW. AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I DON'T. THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
EIGHTEEN. CENTER DRAWS ON.
THANK YOU I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL- IN THIS CASE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL POLICIES ARBITRARILY
DENY INDIVIDUALS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FAIR AND
APPROPRIATE CONSIDERATION OF
THEIR CASE THE NINE JUDICIAL
CONSIDERATION DOES NOT MAKE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFER GRANTING JUDGES
THE DISCRETION TO LEVY THE
SENTENCE THEY BELIEVED TO BE
SUITABLE SHOULD BE A COMMON
SENSE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR OUR SENTENCING
LAWS. FOR THESE REASONS I ALSO
URGE AN IDOL THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CENTER SKINNER WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. I ASKED HER
ABOUT THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. ADKINS HI
BAIT NO BACKER I FORGES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM HI
COURTESY. DALLY NO DOG HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ HI GROSS NO HERTZBERG
I WAS SO HI HER TADO NO JONES
NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON HI WIRE FIVE
MELINDA'S NO MEN. HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A TRUE OF BOTH. NO
PAN. I FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER FIVE STERN
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL KNOW. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSA MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I. CORTESE I. STERN.
HIGHS TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN
MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ON TO TWO TWENTY SIX FOLLOWING
INTO TWENTY SIX WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FORTY THREE
CENTER LABOR FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RAMEAU SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FORTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATING TO APPRENTICESHIPS
CENTER LEVEL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX FORTY THREE
REQUIRES A SCHOOL OR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY TO CONTACT
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PRECEDING A COLLEGE OR CAREER
FAIR ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE
MADE AWARE OF AND HAVE ACCESS
TO LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS SERVE A VARIETY OF
IMPORTANT PURPOSES BY BOTH
EXPANDING THE SKILLED WORKFORCE
AND PROVIDING APPRENTICES WITH
COMPETITIVE WAGES EARN AS YOU
LEARN MODEL HAS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE IN PROVIDING ACCESS
AND OPPORTUNITY TO THE JOB
MARKET FOR ALL WORKERS IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS AND YOUTH HAVE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF THESE PROGRAMS IF THEY SO
CHOOSE AND CAMPUS CAREER FAIRS
ARE AMONG THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
INTRODUCTION TO THE VAST
POSSIBILITIES OF LIFE AFTER
GRADUATION TO THAT END WE MUST
ENSURE THAT TRADE
APPRENTICESHIPS ARE PRESENTED
AS AN OPTION AND THIS BILL WILL
ACCOMPLISH JUST THAT MEMBERS
ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. THE DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON FILE IN TWO TWENTY
SIX MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE AN M. TWO TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH IS SENATOR CORTESE FORCE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC CONTRACTS
SENATOR DAISY THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME. THANK YOU MR. DOES WHAT
WILL. TEST THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTS
RESERVED THE BA FORTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF US SOME MEMORABLE A.
B. EIGHT FORTY SIX RE
AUTHORIZES SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITH PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS
TO UTILIZE JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING FOR A CATALOG OF
SMALLER CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
THE JOB ORDER CONTRACTING IS A
PROJECT DELIVERY METHOD
DESIGNED TO ACCELERATE THE
COMPLETION OF SMALLER PROJECTS
THAT LOWER COSTS BY
STREAMLINING SOME OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS WITHOUT FORGOING
QUALITY THE INTEGRITY OF THE
BIDDING PROCESS FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH LABOR LAWS. AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX DOES NOT REQUIRE DISTRICTS
TO USE JOB ORDER CONTRACTS IT'S
SIMPLY AFFORDS THEM THE OPTION
TO DO SO IF THEY CHOOSE TO THE
OVERWHELMING SUCCESS OF THE
VERY FIRST PILOT PROGRAM
AUTHORIZED BY LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE THE LEGISLATURE
SUBSEQUENTLY AUTHORIZED ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO UTILIZE
JOB ORDER CONTRACTS. HE B.
EIGHT FORTY SIX WOULD EXTEND
THE AUTHORIZATION ANOTHER SIX
YEARS I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR TASTE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I
HAD CANS. EIGHT NO BACKER HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM. CORTEZ THREE FIVE HI
DOLLY. GOD HI TORONTO. HI ADNAN
I GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE I GROSS
YEAH NO HURTS BERG. HI WHERE SO
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO CAM
AUGER. LAYERED HI LAVER HI THE
MON HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN.
I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO HOTEL OR
BOTH NO TEN HI FORTUNE TINO HI
RALPH. I RUBIO HI SKINNER. I
STERN NUMBER NINE HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI I WEINER I WILL.
PLEASE CALL THE OFFICE AND
MEMBERS. ALAN I ADKINS. COME BY
OTHER. I. VALLEY NO. CAM AUGER.
I STERN. WELL NO. HIGHS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS NINE MAJOR PASSES
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO FILE AN M. TWO THIRTY THREE
FOLLOWED BY TWO THIRTY FIVE AND
THEN TO THIRTY SIX TO THIRTY
THREE IS SENATOR NEWMAN FIRST
AMONG MEMBER FRIEDMAN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO SALES CENTER
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MY PLACE YOU PRESENT A B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LAURA FRIEDMAN.
AS WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE THE
CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
RESULTED IN A MASSIVE NUMBER OF
UNFORESEEN CANCELLATIONS OF
LIVE EVENTS. OVER THE PAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS THESE
CANCELLATIONS HAVE LED TO A
RANGE OF PROBLEMS FOR BOTH
TICKET BUYERS AND TICKET
SELLERS. IN MANY CASES TICKET
SELLERS LEFT TO ABSORB LOSSES
FROM COVERED NINETEEN. DRIVEN
CANCELLATION DECIDED TO OFFER
SUBSTITUTE PERFORMANCES INSTEAD
OF REFUNDS TO TICKET BUYERS FOR
THOSE CANCEL EVENTS. IN FACT
SOME COMPANIES IN THE FACE OF
THE UNPRECEDENTED STRAIN OF
SUDDENLY HAVING TO REFUND
THOUSANDS OF TICKETS AT ONCE.
QUIETLY AMENDED THEIR CUSTOMER
TERMS OF SERVICE IS SERVICE
RETROACTIVELY TO REMOVE REFUND
GUARANTEES AND REPLACE THEM
WITH THE OPTION OF A SUBSTITUTE
PERFORMANCE THEREBY RELIEVING
THEMSELVES OF THE OBLIGATION.
FOR A REFUND CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENTLY PROVIDES A TICKET
BUYER MAY REQUEST A REFUND WHEN
AN EVENT IS CANCELED
RESCHEDULED OR POSTPONED
CURRENT LAW HOWEVER. DOES NOT
STATE HOW QUICKLY A CUSTOMER
SHOULD RECEIVE HIS OR HER MONEY
BACK FROM A TICKET SELLER A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX CENTS
DEADLINES FOR TICKET SELLERS TO
PROPERLY MAKE REFUNDS TO TICKET
BUYERS. REQUIRING THAT THE
TICKET PRICE FOR A CANCELED
EVENT BE REFUNDED NOT LATER
THAN THIRTY DAYS OF THE EVENT
CANCELLATION AND THAT THE
TICKET PRICE FOR POSTPONE A
RESCHEDULE VENT BE FULLY
REFUNDED. WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
A REQUEST BY THE TICKET BUYER
AS PERFORMANCE VENUES HAVE ONCE
AGAIN. BEGUN TO PRESENT EVENTS
IN THIS NEW BUT STILL
COMPLICATED ENVIRONMENT A. B.
FIFTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THE RULES FOR REFUNDS
ARE CLEAR TO BOTH TICKET BUYERS
AND SELLERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS. BATES BACKER ARE YOU
FOR JUST I BRADFORD I COME A I
DON'T I PARTS HAS HE I DALLY.
HI TODD HI DURAZO I EXAMINED
EYE LASER EYE CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO FIVE JONES I CAN
LONGER. I LAYERED I. LEIVA HI
THE MOON. HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S
FIVE MILLION FIVE NEWMAN I
NELSON. BUT SHOW BOTH. PAN I
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BABIES. GROVE NIELSEN.
CONTROL OF BOTH. I STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS NOES ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO- FILE ITEM- TWO
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS SENATOR
WIENER FOR SOME THE MEMBER VIA
PADILLA. CENTER WINNERS READY
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THIRTY NINE BY SEVEN
MEMBER BE A POODLE AND ACT
RELATING TO ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
NINE EXPANDS CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO REDUCE CONSUMER
WASTE BY REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
GLASS BOTTLES MAKING THEIR WAY
TO LANDFILLS. IT ALSO HELPS
SMALL FAMILY WINERIES REDUCE
OVERHEAD COSTS RELATED TO
BUYING NEW BOTTLES UNDER
EXISTING LAW CONSUMERS MUST
PURCHASE A SINGLE USE GLASS
BOTTLE OF WINE AND TASTING
ROOMS. ARE ONE REASON NOT
ALLOWED TO REFILL CONSUMERS
SUPPLIED REFILLABLE BOUGHT
BOTTLES ALSO KNOWN AS GROWLERS
IN THEIR TASTING ROOM- THIS
RESEARCHER WAS TEMPORARILY
LIFTED DURING A PANDEMIC BY
ABC- AND WE NEED TO MAKE THIS
PERMANENT THE BEER INDUSTRY
ALREADY IS ALLOWED TO- FILL A
REFILL- GROWLERS. AND WE SHOULD
PROVIDE THE SAME- PROVISION. TO
WINERIES RESPECT FOR US FOR
LIVE- THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. OR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SEEING NONE MEMBERS THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL AND
VIOLENT AND TWO THIRTY FIVE.
SEEING NONE EYES THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE AN M. TWO
THIRTY SIX. CENTER CORTESE
FIRST REMEMBER GRACE CENTER FOR
DAISY IS READY SECRETARY PLEASE
RE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AN
ACT RELATING. TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT THERE CORTESE. I
THINK IT WAS PRESIDENT AND-
SENATORS MAYBE TWO THIRTY SEVEN
PROHIBITS PUBLIC EMPLOYERS FROM
TERMINATING THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE OF EMPLOYEES AND THEIR
DEPENDENTS DURING THE WORK
STOPPAGE OR STRIKE. THERE'S NO
EXCUSE TO LEVERAGE A FAMILY'S
ABILITY TO ACCESS MEDICAL CARE
AS A MECHANISM TO BREAK A
STRIKE. STATE LAW SHOULD BE
CLEAR THAT EVEN THE THREAT OF
SUCH A TACTIC IS AN OF ITSELF
AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE IN
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
NEVER ENGAGE IN SUCH ACTIVITY.
EIGHTY TWO. ACROSS THE BOARD
FOR ALL PUBLIC EMPLOYERS THE
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY OUR
TEACHERS NURSES FIREFIGHTERS
AND MANY OTHERS IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT ABLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE AND TWO
THIRTY SIX. IN DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA I.
ATKINS BABIES. BACKER FORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTESE I
DALLY. NO GOD. I THINK THEY'RE
AWESOME HI ADNAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROVE NO HERTZBERG
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO. I
JONES NO CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LLEVA HI THE MON. FIVE
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN.
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO WHAT SHOW
UP BOTH. I CAN HI PORTS AND YOU
KNOW HI RALPH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AMBERG I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER I WELL NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALAN. AT KINS BAYTEX NO BECKER
I PORGES NO. MAN I STERN. HIGHS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT MAJOR
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON
I'VE FILE ITEM TWO FORTY WHICH
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY TWO FORTY
TWO TO FORTY THREE AND TWO
FORTY EIGHT FILE ITEM TWO FORTY
IS SENATOR BATES FOR SOME THE
MEMBER FRIEDMAN. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
SUPPORT ANIMALS. SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I AM
WRITING TO PRESENTTHEIR PHONE
BEHALF ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
BABY FOR SIXTY EIGHT WILL MAKE
IT CLEAR THAT EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
ANIMALS ARE NOT ENTITLED. TO
THE SAME RIGHTS AND PRIVILEGES
AS GUIDE TO SIGNAL OR SERVICE
DOGS. BABY SIX FOUR SIXTY WILL
HELP CURTAIL THE MISINFORMATION
AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT DOGS AND
THEY'RE IDENTIFYING A QUICK
MEN. HAVE THE SAME ACCESS
RIGHTS AS TRAINED SERVICE DOGS.
IN THIS WILL CREATE FOR A SAFER
PUBLIC SPACE FOR ALL ESPECIALLY
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. WHO
RELY ON TASK TRAINED SERVICE
DOGS FOR INDEPENDENCE. THE BILL
AS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
IN BOTH ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
POLICY COMMITTEE. COMMITTEES I
REQUEST YOUR I. VOTE. FOR
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM ANY OPPOSITION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO MAJOR PASSES. MOVE
MEMBERS ARE MOVING OUT OF
FALLEN TO FORTY TWO WHICH IS
SENATOR HER TADO. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGAR CURRY AN ACT RELATING TO
FOOD LABELING CENTER TARA.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT A B. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I DEAR CURRENT.
EIGHTY FIVE THREE FIVE
ESTABLISHES CLEAR GUIDELINES
FOR WHEN THE CALIFORNIA OLIVE
OIL AND SHE CAN USE IT FROM
CALIFORNIA AND ITS PRODUCT
LABELING AND MARKETING. WE TALK
A LOT ABOUT SUPPORTING FAMILY
FARMERS IN THE CAPITAL BUT
FRANKLY WE- DON'T DO A WHOLE
LOT DIFFERENT THAN WHEN THE
MARKET PLACE CENTERS THIS IS
OUR CHANCE TO SHOW THAT WHILE
WE- ASK A LOT WE WILL FIGHT FOR
THEM AND WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA BRAND IS PROTECTED.
AND CONSUMERS KNOW WHAT THEY
ARE PAYING FOR WHAT A BRAND
CALLED THEMSELVES CALIFORNIAN.
RECENT AMENDMENTS REMOVE
OPPOSITION FROM PRIMARY
OPPONENTS CALIFORNIA OLIVE
RANCH AND THIS HAS A SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EXPORT I
RESPECT LAST NIGHT. MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER BOARD JUST TO
RECOGNIZE HIM AS PRESIDENT I
JUST WANTED TO- GRADUATE ALL
THE FOLKS WHO WERE PART OF
MAKING THIS- BILL HAPPEN AS THE
SPONSOR INDICATED. THIS IS THE
WAY THAT WE CAN PROTECT- THE
VALUE OF CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS
WHILE MAKING CERTAIN THAT
CONSUMERS ARE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
TAKING AN N. H. ORIGIN SO THIS
IS A VERY VERY GOOD AND
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BARGES ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
ALAN. ALL AND THERE'S A STANDBY
CENTER ALAN WE'RE GETTING YOUR
MEDICARE NUMBER. SURROUNDS
MOVING TO THE MIDDLE PART
NUMBERS I JUST WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE HARD
WORK OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE CHAIR. WHO HELPED TO
BROKER THIS- WHAT ACTUALLY WAS
A VERY COMPLICATED NEGTIATIONS
UP. AND IT WAS IT IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF GOOD GOVERNMENT LOT
OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE FROM
DIFFERENT PERFECT PERSPECTIVE
GETTING TOGETHER TO WORK ON
THIS AND- WE GOT TO A VERY GOOD
PLACE IT'S GONNA GONNA GONNA DO
RIGHT BY THE SUPPORT INDUSTRY
AND BY CONSUMERS AS WELL SO.
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. PROGRAMS
SUCH A GREAT DISCUSSION AT THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. WE
DO HAVE AN OBJECTION SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. OUR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. HI ARCHULETA
NINE ATKINS BABIES R. PARKER.
FOR JUST FIVE BRADFORD. HI BY
ADAM. HI CORTEZ HE HI SALLY. I
DON I TORONTO HI EXAMINED EYE
LASER EYE OPENS ALL ITS HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI
HER TADO HI JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED I LIVE ON I LIVE
ALONE. I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN I NEWMAN I NELSON I WOULD
SHOW UP BOTH. HI PAM I FORTUNE
TINO. RALPH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER.
I STERN AMBERG FIVE BY CAL SKI.
I WINNER FIVE WELL. I THIS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BACKER I GROVE I MELINDA'S.
FORTINO I. STERN HI IS THIRTY
SEVEN IT KNOWS. MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON THE FILE
AND TWO FORTY THREE CENTER WAY
SO. SENATORS READY SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AN ACT RELATING
TO CARE FACILITIES SENT AWAY SO.
YES THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT ON
BEHALF OF ONE OF THE WORKERS
SEE I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT A.
B. SIX SIX FIVE TODAY THIS BILL
REQUIRES VARIOUS CARE
FACILITIES WITH EXISTING
INTERNET SERVICE. TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST ONE INTERNET ACCESS
DEVICE DEDICATED FOR RESIDENTS
DUE TO THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC VISITATIONS AND SOCIAL
INTERACTIONS IN THESE
FACILITIES WERE RESTRICTED TO
STOP THE SPREAD HOWEVER THESE
MEASURES CAN CAUSE RESIDENTS TO
EXPERIENCE ISOLATION AND
LONELINESS SO. HAVING AN INNER
INTERNET ACCESS DEVICE CAN
REALLY HELP THE PEOPLE OF
WHETHER THESE CONDITIONS THEY
ALSO ALLOW THEM TO CONNECT-
LOVE LOVE LOVE ONCE AGAIN
GAUGE. IN VIRTUAL COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS AND RECEIVE TELEHEALTH
SERVICES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS BIPARTISAN
MEASURE TO PROMOTE RESIDENTS
QUALITY OF LIFE. I THINK YOU
SAID IT WAS SO THIS- ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM NUMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL INVALID IN
TWO FORTY THREE. SEEING NONE
ICE THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON A FILE INTO FORTY
EIGHT. SENATOR NEWMAN SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI
AN ACT RELATING TO POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION CENTER
NEWMAN- THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
AB ONE THOUSAND TWO OTHER BY
SIMPLY MEMBER CHOI THE REQUEST
THE UC SYSTEM ADDRESS THE CSU
SYSTEM TO FORMULATE A
CONSISTENT POLICY TO RECOGNIZE
A MILITARY SERVICE SERVICE
MEMBERS JOINT SERVICE
TRANSCRIPT AN AWARD APPROPRIATE
COURSE CREDIT FOR THE PRIOR
COURSES AND OR TRAINING. THIS
MEASURE HAS SUPPORT SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU SIR NORMAN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM THIS ITEM QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL AND FILE
ITEM TWO FORTY EIGHT. SEEING
NONE HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FIFTY SIX WHICH WILL BE FILED-
FOLLOWED BY TWO FIFTY SEVEN AND
TWO FIFTY EIGHT. SENATOR
CORTESE ON TO FIT ON A FILE AND
TWO FIFTY SIX. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE AN ACT TO RELATE RELATING
TO DIVERSION. SECRETARY ZINKE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT OF
SINNERS HE B. THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN
EXTENDS THE SUNSET FOR THE
TRANSITIONALAGE YOUTH PILOT
PROGRAM TO HELP ENSURE
CONTINUITY IN PROGRAMMING AND
SUPPORT FOR YOUNG ADULTS AGE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE. THE
TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH PILOT
PROGRAM ALLOWS ONLY THOSE WHO
HAVE COMMITTED NON SERIOUS
NONVIOLENT AND NON SEX OFFENSES
TO RECEIVE SERVICES IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM INSTEAD OF AN
ADULT FACILITY. THE PROGRAM IS
AIMED AT PROVIDING YOUNG ADULTS
WITH AGE APPROPRIATE SERVICES
INCLUDING COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
AND VOCATIONAL TRAINING. THE
REASON THESE YOUTH ARE LEGALLY
ADULTS. SIZE DEMONSTRATES THOSE
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OLD ARE STILL UNDERGOING
SIGNIFICANT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
MAKING THEM MORE RECEPTIVE TO
COGNITIVE REHABILITATION AND
CHANGES IN DECISION MAKING.
THIS VOLUNTARY PROGRAM ALLOWS
SYSTEM INVOLVED YOUTH TO HAVE
THE CHARGES DISMISSED UPON
COMPLETION OF THE PROGRAM TO
REMOVE BARRIERS AND SET THEM ON
A POSITIVE PATH FORWARD. THE
BILL WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET
FOR THE TRANSITIONAL AGE YOUTH
PILOT PROGRAM THE JANUARY. ONE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO ENSURE
CONTINUITY IN THESE SERVICES
FOR YOUNG ADULTS. BUT A
PERMANENT PATH WITH THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON FILE AND TWO FIFTY
SIX. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI HI
ARCHULETA I. ATKINS BATES.
BACKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
KERR THEY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DALLY NO DODD. I- ALSO I AIKMAN
EYE LASER HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI FURTADO NO JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED I LABOUR HI
THE MOON. HI WIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NELSON NO A
SHOW OF BOTH. HI TAM I FORTUNE
TINO HI ROSS I RUBIO. I SKINNER
FIVE STERN BERGER HI WHAT KIND
OF C. I. WINNER. FIVE WELL NO
PLEASE CALL THEM SOME MEMBERS
ATKINS BASICS. FOR JUST. STERN
HIGHS TWENTY NINE KNOWS SEVEN
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR GLAZIER IS
READY SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SOMEBODY FELL THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN
ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. SURVEYS ARE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FINE SERVICE
TODAY- TO OUR SENATE. AMBER'S
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WOULD
INCREASE PENALTIES FOR THE
EGREGIOUS PERSONAL USE OF
CAMPAIGN FUNDS. UP TO TWO TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF THE UNLAWFUL
EXPENDITURE THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION. HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IS ESSENTIAL
TO THE POLITICAL PROCESS THIS
CONFIDENCE DETERIORATES WHEN A
PUBLIC OFFICIAL USES CAMPAIGN
FUNDS FOR PERSONAL BENEFITS.
THE DETERIORATION PROCESS. IS
AGGREGATED EVADED WHEN THE
AMOUNT OF THE PERSONAL USE IS
ESPECIALLY HIGH THE F. PPC IS
DISCOVERED MANY CASES WHERE
PUBLIC OFFICIALS HAVE USED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
VACATIONS GAMBLING HOME
RENOVATIONS AND MANY OTHERS. AS
YOU ALL KNOW CAMPAIGN
EXPENDITURES MUST BE REASONABLY
RELATED TO A POLITICAL
GOVERNMENTAL OR LEGISLATIVE
PURPOSE THE CURRENT MAXIMUM
PENALTY IS CURRENTLY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS- THIS BILL
INCREASES THAT. BY TWO TIMES
THAT WILL NOT ONLY DID HER THIS
COULD CORRUPT PRACTICE BUT ALSO
EMPOWER THE F. PPC TO SET A
PENALTY PROPORTIONAL TO THE
VIOLATION. WITH WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THEM ROLL CALL ON FILE IN TWO
FIFTY SEVEN. SEEING NO
OBJECTION EYES THIRTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE IN TWO FIFTY EIGHT. CENTER
BRADFORD SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FORTINO SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE CENTER
BEDFORD. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FORTINO SEVEN WILL
PROVIDE OUR STATE'S NURSES WITH
THE TOOLS TO RECOGNIZE AND
ADDRESS IMPLICIT BIAS IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY
THIS MEASURE REQUIRES NURSING
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND HOSPITALS
INCLUDE IMPLICIT BIAS.
EDUCATION FOR NURSES. THE
PRESENCE OF IMPLICIT BIAS IN
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM LEE SAID
DIFFERENCES IN THE QUALITY OF
CARE GIVEN TO PATIENTS AS WELL
AS OUR OVERALL LIFE OUTCOMES
EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AND WOMEN ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THIS BUYS I CAN
SPEAK FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
MY MOTHER WAS A NURSE FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS AND SHE SHARED MANY
OF THESE- BIASES THAT EXISTED
IN THE HEALTH CARE FOR THE
PROFESSION REQUIRING A PULITZER
BY TRAINING FOR NURSES. BRINGS
AWARENESS. OF THEE ISSUES THIS
BILL ALSO IS ONE OF A FURTHER
STEPS TOWARD ELIMINATING THE
NEGATIVE HEALTHCARE IMPACT OF
RACIAL AND OTHER BIASES IN OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND I WAS
RECKLESS RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ATTENDEES BAIT I
BACKER. HI FOR JUST BRADFORD HI
I PROVIDE A HIGH CORTESE HI
DALLY. DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
ADNAN. HI GLAZER I CAN DOLLARS
HI GROSS. I WENT SO HI HER TADO
I JONES NO CAN LONGER. HI THERE
I LLEVA HI THE MOON I WHERE I.
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. TOTAL OF BOTH I CAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI ROSS I
RUBIO HI SKINNER. FIVE STERNE
NUMBERED RIGHT HI WHAT KIND OF
SKI I WINNER I WILL. YES PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
PORGES DALLY. GROVE MELINDA'S.
NIELSEN STERN. WELL. HIGHS
THIRTY ONE KNOWS ONE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON
TO FILE AN M. TWO SIXTY TWO
SENATOR BECKER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLEN AN ACT RELATING TO PARK
DISTRICT'S CENTER RECORD GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS EIGHTY NINE
FIVE NINE WOULD ALLOW
INDEPENDENT PARK DISTRICTS TO
ADDRESS THE MULTITUDE OF PUBLIC
NEWS NUISANCES THAT THEY
CONFRONT REGULARLY. EXAMPLES
INCLUDE ILLEGAL WATER DIVERSION
AND ILLEGAL DUMPING THEY NEED
TO BE ADDRESSED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THESE ENCROACHMENTS IN
THE SAME WAY THAT CITIES
COUNTIES AND OTHER SPECIAL
DISTRICTS CAN. I ASK FOR YOUR
I. VOTE. THANK YOU SIR BECKER
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON TWO
SIXTY TWO. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I ADKINS BAIT.
BACKER HI FORGES HI BRADFORD. I
HAVE A HI COURTESY HI DALLY I
DONT HI TORONTO I HAD BEEN I
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HI GROSS I
HEARD SOME BURG. HI WITH SO. HI
HER TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED I LABOR HI THE MON HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S. I MEN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BUT SHOW BOTH
I CAN HI FORTINO. HI RALPH I
REVIEW I SKINNER. FIVE STERN
NUMBER I WORK OWSKI FIVE WINNER
HI WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AT KINS. EIGHT
I NIELSEN I. STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A
FILE AND TWO SIXTY FOUR SENATOR
ROB. SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RECORDS IN A ROW THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS THIS BILL
WILL MAKE NON SUBSTANTIVE
CHANGES TO REORGANIZE AND
CLARIFY THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
SO IT IS EASIER FOR THE PUBLIC
TO USE AND UNDERSTAND THESE
CHANGES WERE RECOMMENDED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION THIS BOOK SIMPLY
CODIFIES THE COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATION I RESPECTFULLY
AS HE RIVE OF. THANK YOU CENTER
ROBIN MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO NET
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION
EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MOVE ON TO TWO
SIXTY FILE AND TWO SIXTY FIVE
SENATOR ROTH AGAIN SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHILD AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RECORDS ZERO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
LAW REVISION COMMISSION WAS
TASKED WITH DRAFTING NON
SUBSTANTIVE AMENDMENTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
THAT WOULD REDUCE ITS LENGTH
AND COMPLEXITY AVOID
UNNECESSARY CROSS REFERENCES
PLACE RELATED PROVISIONS IN
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO ONE ANOTHER.
AND ELIMINATE DUPLICATIVE
PROVISIONS THIS BILL DOES JUST
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY AS FEAR OF
A- THANK YOU SENARATNE MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. THIS ALSO QUALIFIES
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION ON AN UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SEEING NONE. HIGHS THIRTY
NINE KNOWS ZERO. WE'RE GOING TO
FILE AN M. TWO SIXTY SEVEN.
SENATOR LAYERED ISRAELI
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD AN ACT
RELATING TO PRIVACY CENTER
ALERT. THERE WE GO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- AB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE SERVES AS AN EFFECTIVE
FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING THE
GROWTH OF THE HACKED OUT OF
MARKET PLACE BY MAKING CLEAR
THAT NO ONE CAN KNOWINGLY SELL
PURCHASE OR UTILIZE TAX DATA
THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES I
ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK
YOU SENATOR LARRY ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE MEMBERS IS
ALSO QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION ON
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING NONE. EYES THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IS ZERO MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE IT INTO SIXTY
NINE SENATOR HERTZBERG'S
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IN THIS AREA AN
ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT CENTERS FOR. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE MR
PRESIDENT THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WE CALLED HIM UNCLE
MILTIE MARKS TOGETHER WITH MIKE
BRUCE. AUTHORED THE MARKS ROOTS
LOCAL BOND PULLING IT'S ALREADY
ACTIVE NINETY FIVE WITH JESS
UNRUH. ASSIST ISSUE RATE
REDUCTION BONDS TO REDUCE THE
COST OF BORROWING FROM
UTILITIES THIS MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AREA AND
EXPANDS THE TYPE OF PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES TO CONDITION
RATE REDUCTION BONDS
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU CEREBRA
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FOLLOW HIM TO
SEVENTY ONE WHICH WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY TWO SEVENTY TWO AND
TWO SEVENTY FOUR FULL AND TWO
SEVENTY ONE IS SENATOR CAFIERO.
SHE IS READY SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY
THREE BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON ACT GROUP CULTURE AND
ACTUALLY THE AGRICULTURE CENTER
CARRIER THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY THREE
WHICH IS THE ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEES OMNIBUS
BILL FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE
GOAL OF THE FOUR THINGS ONE A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA EXPOSITION
AND STATE FAIR WHICH IS CAL
EXPO TO REGAIN THE USE OF
OPPORTUNITY PURCHASING TO
REQUIRE THE FAIR BOARD MEMBERS
TO COMPLETE REQUIRED TRAINING
BEFORE THEY ARE ALLOWED TO DO
THEIR DUTIES AS FAIR BOARD
MEMBERS. THREE WILL ALLOW THE
CALIFORNIA APPLE COMMISSION TO
LOWER THE NUMBER OF APPLE
COMMISSION DISTRICTS GIVEN THAT
WE LOST 60% OF THE APPLE
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE AND FOR
CHANGE THE PERIOD OF TIME IN
WHICH A CERTIFIED FARMERS
MARKET CERTIFICATE IS VALID
FROM TWELVE MONTHS FROM THE
DATE OF ISSUE TO UP TO TWELVE
MONTHS THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR COME THERE- ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM THIS ALSO QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SEEING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES- MOVING ON A FILE I. TO
SEVENTY TWO. SENATOR WILK
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VALLADARES AN ACT RELATIVE TO
FIRST LADY NANCY DAVIS REAGAN
CENTER WILL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYWOMAN VALLEY DARES AT
PERCENT AC AC ARE NINETY FOUR.
WHICH HONORS THE LIFE AND
LEGACY OF FORMER FIRST LADY
NANCY REAGAN ON THE CENTENNIAL
OF HER BIRTH. IN OUR LONG LIFE
NANCY REAGAN WORE MANY HATS SHE
WAS AN ACTRESS LOVING WIFE AND
MOTHER TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR
SEVERAL IMPORTANT CAUSES AND OF
COURSE FIRST LADY BOTH
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES SHE PASSIONATELY
ADVOCATED FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH.
AS FIRST LADY NANCY PUBLICLY
REVEALED HER BREAST CANCER
DIAGNOSIS AND DECISION TO
UNDERGO A MASTECTOMY. HER
WILLINGNESS TO SHARE HER
CONDITION ENCOURAGE OTHER WOMEN
TO SEEK MEDICAL ADVICE. SHE
CHAMPIONED THE NEEDS FOR
RESEARCH IN THE PROVISION
PREVENTION TREATMENT CARE OF
ELSE HYMERS. AFTER HER
HUSBAND'S DIAGNOSIS WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE NANCY
REAGAN BECAME A TIRELESS
ADVOCATE FOR CURE FOR THE
DISEASE. AND FOR THOSE AFFECTED
BY IT. JUST ON A PERSONAL BASIS
I HAD A SEASON WITH NANCY
REAGAN BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO I WAS THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER
FOR AROUND. MARINE REAGAN WHO
IS RUNNING FOR CONGRESS AND I
GOT TO SEE NANCY UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL AS A DOTING WIFE TO
HUSBAND WHO CLEARLY AT THAT
TIME WAS STRUGGLING WITH L.
TIMERS EVEN THOUGH IT WASN'T
PUBLICLY REVEALED UNTIL
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. AND JUST
AS A STEPMOTHER WHO CALLED IN
EVERY DAY TO SEE HOW HER
DAUGHTER DAUGHTER WAS DOING.
AND I'M STANDING HERE TODAY IN
THE SENATE I'LL BE BY RADICALLY
BECAUSE A NANCY REAGAN BACK ON
MARCH ELEVENTH. TWENTY SIXTEEN
WAS THE LAST DAY TO FILE FOR
OFFICE I HAD EVERY INTENTION OF
RUNNING FOR REELECTION TO THE
STATE ASSEMBLY. HIDE WITH HAD
THE HONOR OF BEING INVITED TO
NANCY REAGAN'S FUNERAL AND I
WAS SO INSPIRED BY THE EVENTS
THAT OCCURRED THAT DAY- I
DECIDED TO SWITCH SEATS IN IN
RUN FOR THE SENATE SO I OWE I
OWE A LOT ACTUALLY TO NANCY
REAGAN. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK- AND I VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU. YOU
SENT A WELCOME MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS. A C. R. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI ADKINS. BATES I
BACKER. HI PORGES FIVE BRADFORD.
I COME BY ADAM. CORTEZ HE HI
DALLY HI TODD HI THERE ALSO HI
EGGMAN. I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES. NO GROWTH. I
HURTS BURKE HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES I CAN'T LONGER NO
LAYERED I LLEVA. LET ALONE. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN.
NEWMAN NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM HI FOR TO DO YOU
KNOW. HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER NO STERN AMBERG HI BY
KELSEY. WINNER NO WELL HI.
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS
ATKINS CABRERA I. LABOUR MAN.
NEWMAN I STERN HI CASCADE.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS FOR
MAJOR PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ON A FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY FOUR
SENATOR DELHI. SECRETARY PLEASE
RE. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTEEN
BY FAMILY MEMBER MEGHAN DALLY
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE
ATTENDANCE CENTER DAILY. YEAH
DO YOU MET THE MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB FIVE SIXTEEN STRAIGHT FOR
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW K. TWELVE
STUDENTS TO. BE EXCUSED FROM
SCHOOL WHEN THEIR ABSENCE. BAR
FOR PARTICIPATING IN CULTURAL
CEREMONIES THIS BILL WAS ON%
CONSENT BUT WAS PULLED OFF. DUE
TO AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
CAPTURING OUT CONCERNS IT
PASSED ON CONSENT THROUGH EVERY
SENATE COMMITTEE AND HAS NO
VOTES OR OPPOSITION ARJUN AIBO.
THANK YOU SENATOR DALLY ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THIS IS ALSO CALLED.
THIRTY EIGHT. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING NONE THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NO OBJECTION
EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MERCER MOVING
ON A FILE AND TWO EIGHTY ONE
FOLLOWED BY. TWO EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHT
AND TWENTY NINE. SO TWO EIGHTY
ONE IS SENATOR WIENER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WARD AND AFTER RELATED TO
HOUSING SERINA THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I'M PRESENTING
COLLEAGUES EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
ONE- WAS A SET OF STATEWIDE
STANDARDS TO ENSURE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESIDENTS HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO COMMON ENTRANCES%
AREAS AND AMENITIES. AS MARKET
RATE HOUSING RESIDENTS ARE
CURRENTLY DEVELOPER SEEKING TO
BUILD A MIXED USE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT- WITH- THE FOR
MIXED INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT WITH BOTH
AFFORDABLE AND MARKET RATE
UNITS CAN CREATE SEPARATE
COMMON ENTRANCES AND AREAS AND
AMENITIES- THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RESIDENTS ARE EXCLUDED
FROM ACCESSING THIS MEANS THAT
THE AFFORDABLE- UNIT OCCUPANTS
ARE EFFECTIVELY SEGREGATED FROM
THE MARKET RATE. UNIT OCCUPANTS
AND BARRED FROM USING- THESE
COMMON AREAS AND AMENITIES THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY A FORM OF CLASS
DISCRIMINATION- IN A REALLY ON
THEIR MINDS WERE TRYING TO DO
IN TERMS OF MIXING TOM HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS IN CALIFORNIA WE
WANT EVERYONE TO BE LIVING
TOGETHER- TO BE SHARING THE
SAME. AMENITIES AS WE MOVE TO
BUILD MORE HOUSING CALIFORNIA
WE WILL HAVE MORE AND MORE ON
MIXED USE RCV MIXED INCOME
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND THE
REASON THAT THIS IN THE BUD NOW
AND SET. THE STANDARD OF
RESPECT WELLS FARGO. M. AS IN
DISCUSSION OF ON FILE INTO A
ANY. OR TO. SEEING NONE THIS
QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING NONE. EYES THIRTY EIGHT
KNOWS ZERO MAJOR PASSES. MOVING
ON. THE FILE IN TWO EIGHTY TWO.
SIR MCGUIRE. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS IN A
REPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
RETAIN TO- SIMMONS- SENATE
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR BY THE HARD
WORKING AS A MEMBER FRIEDMAN
THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES
THAT. PERMIT FEE CAPS CHARGE
FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS APPLY
TO SOURCES MANAGER CARPORTS
PATIO COVERS AND SHADE
STRUCTURES. WELL IT STREAMLINES
THAT PROCESS- INPUT A CAP ON
THOSE FEES THE OTHERS OFFICES
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THE
PERMITTING FEE CAP DO NOT APPLY
TO LARGE UTILITY SCALE SYSTEMS
THAT WAS A IMPORTANT ONE AS IT
WAS GOING THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS. IT'S THIS BILL'S
RECEIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE ON BEHALF OF
SOME NUMBER FOR YOU. THANK YOU
SIR MAGUIRE'S ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM VOLUNTARY.
TO ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SO
PLEASE READ. OUR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS BABIES. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD HI HAVE ITEM
ONLINE FOR TESTING I DALLY. GOD
HI TORONTO I EGGMAN I BLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. FIVE
HURTS BURKE I WAS SO I- DON'T I
JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LABOUR HI THE MON I WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN HI NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO CONTROL OF BOTH. CAN
FIVE FOURTEEN TINA. I. ROSS I
REVIEW I SKINNER I STERN ON
BURKE HI I HAVE SKI. I WINNER I
WILL HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS BATES NO.
PORGES DALLY. A TROUBLED. STERN.
SIZE THIRTY TWO KNOWS THREE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING
ON A FILE AND TWO EIGHTY THREE.
SENATOR ROB SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
EIGHTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
AN ACT RELATING TO HOSPICE
CENTER OFF THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THIS BILL TAKES
IMPORTANT STEPS TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS AND ROLLING IN HOSPICE
CARE ARE NOT SUBJECT TO ILLEGAL
INDUCEMENTS THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT HOSPICE CARE IS
AND THAT THEIR ELECTION OF
HOSPICE INFORMED CONSENT AND
COUNSELING. ARE COMPLETED BY
THE APPROPRIATE PROFESSIONALS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENARATNE MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THIS ITEM QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL INVALID IN TWO EIGHTY
THREE. SEEING NONE. EYES THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE AND TWO
EIGHTY FOUR CENTER ADMIN.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE AN ACT
RELATING TO ENERGY CENTER
ADMIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT A B. THREE THREE TWENTY
TWO ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY
MEMBER SOLACE IS HAS TO DO WITH
BIOMASS- AND IT DIRECTS THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
CONSIDER BIOMASS UNDER NEW AND
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS AND THE
EPIC PROGRAM- WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S WASTE WE KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE NOT LIKE US TO DO
ANYTHING WITH ALL THAT WASTE
BUT AS LONG AS THIS WORLD STILL
HAS THINGS ALIVE WE'LL HAVE
WAIT. TO DO SOMETHING WITH OUR
FOREST PRODUCTS WITH OUR AG
WASTE AND THE BEST WAY TO DO
THAT IS TO MAKE CLEAN ENERGY
AND TAKE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
OTHERWISE BE UP OPEN BURNS OR
LEAD TO WILDFIRES. IN OUR
FORESTS AND FARMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU SIR AND
CENTRE DELHI. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I. STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION AS-
LAKE TAHOE IS ACTUALLY BEING.
EVACUATED AS WE SPEAK. RIGHT
NOW TODAY- IF WE HAD BIOMASS
PLANTS AVAILABLE CLOSER TO LAKE
TAHOE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
MORE. PROJECTS TO BE ABLE TO
THIN THE FOREST AND TAKE THIS
UP BIOMASS OUT SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I SUPPORT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR TELL ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA I HAVE CANS BABIES
FIVE BECKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI BY ADAM I WAS HEAVY
I DALLY I DON. HI THERE ARE SO
I HAD BEEN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW. HI HURTS
BERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LABOR HI THE MOON. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S I MEN I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I UNTIL A VOTE HI PAM
HI FORTUNE TINO. BRIAN ROSS HI
RUBIO MIKE SKINNER I STERN
AMBERG I WORK OWSKI I WINNER I
WILL. HI PLEASE CALL THE HELP
THE MEMBERS. ALAN ATKINS THE
MON. STERN. HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON
FOLLOWING HIM TO EIGHTY FIVE
CENTER ARCH ALETTA SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. IT'S ONLY ABOUT
EIGHT FIFTY BY FAMILY MEMBER
GALLAGHER AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SENATOR
ARCHULETA THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- THIS BILL. A. B.
EIGHT FIFTY EXTENDS THE SUNSET
ON THE AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
CITIES OF EL MONTE MONTEBELLO
AND WILLIS TO SELL THEIR WATER
UTILITIES. AND ALSO REMOVES A
REQUIREMENT THAT A WATER SYSTEM
BY WHOLLY WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES
OF THE CITIES OF EL MONTE.
MONTEBELLO AND WILL LOOK TO
SELL THEIR WATER UTILITY FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CONSOLIDATING
WITH ANOTHER AGENCY WITHOUT
VOTER APPROVAL N. S. TAX RATE
OUTSIDE THE CITY BOUNDARIES.
THE DEFINITION OF INTERESTING
PERSON WITH THAT I ASK FOR AN
IBOOK. THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THERE IS
THIS QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION TO
USING ANIMALS FOR CALL. SEEING
NONE EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO MEASURE PASSES ARE MOVING
ON TO FILE IT INTO EIGHTY SIX
CENTER LAYERED SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER NEWS
ARIAN AND AFTER RELATING TO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
SAILOR THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
THEY BEFORE SIXTY FIVE WOULD
ENSURE THAT AFFECTED GROUPS GET
CONFIDENT RESPECTFUL SERVICES
BY PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES-
THIS BILL REQUIRES ONE HOUR OF
CULTURAL COMPETENCY TRAINING.
FOR PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES
EVERY THREE YEARS- FOR VARIOUS
GROUPS INCLUDING LGBT Q. ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES AND RELIGIOUS
COMMUNITIES THE AMENDMENTS MADE
ON THE FLOOR CLARIFY THAT
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES
PROVIDE SERVICES IN CONTRAST TO
PHYSICAL CARE DISCOUNT OFF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SIXTY NINE ZERO
I ASKED FOR AN IPHONE. THANK
YOU SIR ARE THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS BASED. BACKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD. HI BY ADAM HI
FOR TESTING HI DALLY. DOT FIVE
TORONTO HI AIKMAN I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE. HERTZBERG
I WAS SO HI HER TADO HI JONES
NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LIVE
ON. HI THE MOON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW BOTH I CAN.
FORTINO HI RALPH I RUBIO HI
SKINNER FIVE STERN AMBERG HI HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE WINNER HI
WELL HI PLEASE CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS. AT KINS FACE. FOR JUST.
BALLY GROVE. MELINDA'S NIELSEN.
PAN STERN. HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
ONE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWO
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR COME LONGER.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE AN ACT
RELATING TO JUVENILES. MR
PRESIDENT I'M REQUESTING THAT
EIGHTY FIVE OH THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE BE MOVED
TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THANK YOU
SIR COLOR DESK WILL NOTE. K.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO NOW
FILE AN M. TWO NINETY FOUR.
FOLLOWED BY TWO NINETY SEVEN
AND THEN SOME MORE IN THE THREE
HUNDREDS TWO NINETY FOUR IS
SENATOR RUBIO. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE
AN ACT RELATING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE REVIEW. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT DAY BE SIX
SEVENTY THREE WHICH HELPS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERVICE
PROVIDERS RECEIVE STATE FUNDING
QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY THE
CURRENT REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS
FOR NONPROFIT TO SLOW IN
ORGANIZATIONS ARE FULLY FORCED
TO WAIT MONTHS TO RECEIVE THEIR
REIMBURSEMENTS. FOR SERVICES
RENDERED MANY HAVING TO TAKE
OUT LOANS JUST TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS OPEN EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY
THREE MAKES A COMMONSENSE
REFORM TO PROVIDE PRE APPROVED
NONPROFIT PROVIDERS WITH 1100%
OF THEIR FIGHTING AT THE START
OF THEIR GRANT PROGRAM. THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL ADDED
CHAPTER NOT LANGUAGE THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED KNOWN NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IFLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE
MEMBERS THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITE ANY OBJECTION TO
MS ROLL CALL. SEEING NONE I
DON'T. STAND BY. AND WE DO. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS ARE
MOVING OUT TO TWO NINETY SEVEN.
SENATOR WIENER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SIXTEEN BY A FAMILY MEMBER TO
AN ACT RELATING TO HOMELESSNESS
ZERO INR THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I WROTE TO
COLLEAGUES ARE PRESENT AV
SIXTEEN- THIS BILL WAS HEAVILY
AMENDED IN THE APPROPRIATION
COMMITTEE- AND IS NOW A SIMPLE
BOTH YOUR REGISTERED
OPPOSITION. AV EIGHT SIXTEEN
PRIORITIZES NATIONAL HOUSING
TRUST FUND DOLLARS FOR
DEVELOPMENTS THAT SERVE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON PROJECTS
THAT USE MEDICAL BENEFITS TO
PAY FOR SERVICES I RESPECT
TRANSFER NOVEL. THANK YOU ST
WINNER ANY- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS BASE. BACKER FIVE PORGES
NO BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM. I
PROTESTING I DALLY NO DODD I
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER. FIVE
DOLLARS I GROSS NO HERTZBERG I
WOULD ASSUME. HI HER TADO FIVE
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LLEVA. HI THE MOON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN I
NELSON NO A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM HI FORTINO. HI ROSS FIVE
RUBIO. HI I. SCANNER HI STERN
I'M BURKE I WAKE OWSKI I WINNER
I WILL. HI THIS CALL THE OTHER
MEMBERS. AT KINS FACE NO.
EASTERN HIGHS THIRTY ONE IT
KNOWS SEVEN MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A FILE
AND THREE OH FIVE THREE OH SIX
AND IN THREE OH NINE WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THREE OH FIVE WHICH
IS CENTER ADMIN. SECRETARY
PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLY ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND ACT RELATING
TO FOOD. CENTER ADMIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR UPDATES THE
COTTAGE FOOD INDUSTRY
REGULATIONS ALLOWING FOR. TO BE
ABLE TO MAIL THINGS AND SHOP
ONLINE JUST TO GET IT UP WITH
TODAY'S STANDARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU CENTER ADMIN. MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE EYES THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON A FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX THREE OF SIX
FILE ITEM THREE OH SIX SENATOR
DODD. SECRETARY PLEASE RE
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND RELATING TO WATER
SERVICE CENTER. YES MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS BILL
WILL AUTHORIZE A WATER UTILITY
COMPANY WITH TEN THOUSAND
CAUGHT CONNECTIONS ARE MORE TO
WAIVE THE TRANSACTION FEE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ELECTRONIC.
PAYMENT OPTIONS RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. WELCOME BACK. THIS
QUALIFIES JAMS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM SEEING NONE MEASURE
PASSES- EYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO MOVING ON ITEM THREE OH
NINE. WE HAVE CENTER WILT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AN ACT
RELATING TO APPRENTICESHIPS
CENTER WORK THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT DOING A GREAT JOB
TODAY I RISE 2% EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY FIVE M. ON BEHALF OF
SOLOMON TOM LACKEY. THIS
LEGISLATION AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
TO THE INTER AGENCY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON APPRENTICESHIPS IT
CREATES A SUBCOMMITTEE TO STUDY
OPPORTUNITIES AFFORDED TO
FORMER FOSTER AND RECENTLY
HOMELESS YOUTH. THE SIXTY
THOUSANDCHILDREN WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPENDENCIES SYSTEM
HAVE EXPERIENCE ADVERSITY THAT
WILL FOREVER ALTER THEIR SENSES
HOOKED UP SECURITY THIS BILL
AIMS TO CONNECT THEM WITH
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
THROUGH APPRENTICESHIPS THAT
ENABLE ON THE JOB TRAINING AND
EARNING AN INCOME WHILE
PURSUING ADVANCED EDUCATION.
THESE YOU WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FLOURISH IN A
CAREER OR MAINTAIN EMPLOYABLE
SKILLS WHILE PURSUING THEIR
PASSION THIS LEGISLATION HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND RECEIVE ZERO NO
VOTES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I VOTE. MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. THIS ITEM QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SEEING NINE. SIZE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A
FILE AND 311-312-3133 FIFTEEN.
AND A FEW MORE AFTER THAT- WE
ARE GOING TO THREE ELEVEN.
WHICH IS SENATOR SKINNER.
SECRETARY PLEASE RE. ASSEMBLE
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WRAP A RAMBLING
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
HEALTH CENTERS HERE. HELLO THE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN VERY
ESSENTIAL IN REDUCING MANY-
BLOOD BORNE DISEASES PAST THAT
WAY LIKE HIV HEPATITIS C. AND
MANY OTHERS. OUR COUNTY HEALTH
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
HAD THE AUTHORITY SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE. TO PROVIDE. THE SYRINGE
EXCHANGE SERVICES IN AREAS
WHERE IT'S DETERMINED THAT
THERE COULD BE A RAPID SPREAD
OF HIV HEPATITIS OR THE OTHER
DISEASES I MENTIONED. WHAT AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR DOES IS
ALLOW OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO PROCEED WITH THE
AUTHORITY THAT THEY HAVE. WITH
AND PROVIDE THESE PROGRAMS WITH
AN EXEMPTION TO SEE CORE
REQUIREMENTS. SO DURING THE
PANDEMIC THERE'S BEEN A SHARP
INCREASE IN OVERDOSE. OVERDOSE
DEATHS THESE PROGRAMS ALSO
PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES TO THE
PERSON THAT IS ADDICTED AND
SAFE DISPOSAL OF SYRINGES. THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
ALLOW OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO UTILIZE THE
AUTHORITY THAT WE PROVIDED THEM
I ASK FOR YOUR VTE. THANK YOU
SIR SKINNER ANY. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SIX NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI HAD
KITTENS HI BASICS NO BACKER. HI
FORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T I PROTESTING HI DELHI.
GOD HI TORONTO I HATE MEN I
PLEASE SIR I CONSOLIDATE MY
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI HI WISH
SO I RETIRED IN. JONES NO CAN
LONGER I LAYERED ON HI BETA I
THE MON HI WIRE. HI MELINDA'S
NO MEN I NEWMAN. HI NIELSEN NO
A SHOW ABOUT. NO PAN HI
FOURTEEN ZERO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO I CAN- FIVE HI STERN ON
BIRDS. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT EMBERS VALLEY. NO
HER TADO. STERN AMBERG. EYES
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON A
FILE AND THREE TWELVE CENTER
LAYERED SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX IT'S A SOME PEOPLE TWELVE
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM AN ACT RELATING TO
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES SIMILAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT AB TWELVE SIXTY SEVEN
CLARIFIES THAT AN ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE MANUFACTURER CAN
ADVERTISE AND DONATE A PORTION
OF THE PROCEEDS OF THE SALE. OF
AN ALCOHOL. THEY'VE BEEN KNOWN
VOTES NO NO VOTES IN EITHER
HOUSE OR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
I ASKED FOR AN I. PHONE.
NUMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NONE HIGHS THIRTY
NINE IT KNOWS IS ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON A FILE AND
THREE THIRTEEN CENTER FORTINO.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AN
ACT RELATING TO EQUESTRIAN
SAFETY CENTER BORN TO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND SENATORS
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR IS A
SAFETY MEASURE THAT WILL
REQUIRE MINERS TO WEAR A HELMET
WHEN RIDING A HORSE ON A PAVED
HIGHWAY AND MANDATE THAT ALL
WRITERS ARE THERE A QUIENES-
REFER. HERE FOR A LIGHT AT
SUNDOWN ON OCTOBER EAT ON AN
OCTOBER EVENING IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN A VEHICLE STRUCK TWO
INDIVIDUALS RIDING THEIR HORSES
IN THE COMMUNITY OF LAKE VIEW
TERRACE OF LOS ANGELES THE
CRASH TRAGICALLY KILLED TWO
HORSES AND LEFT TWO RIDERS IN
CRITICAL CONDITION. SIMILAR CAN
OKAY COLLISIONS HAVE OCCURRED
IN COMMUNITIES OF SAUGUS AND
WILTON- AND IT IS COMMON FOR
HORSES TO SHARE THE ROAD WITH
VEHICLES HOWEVER CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR DRIVERS TO SEE
RIDERS AND THEIR HORSES IN THE
DARK. WHEN THESE COLLISIONS
OCCUR THE RIDERS USUALLY THROWN
OFF THEIR HORSE LEAVING THEM IN
CRITICAL CONDITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
ON THIS IMPORTANT SAFETY
MEASURE. THANK YOU SIR POINTING
OUT MEMBERS NEED DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE THIS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ OUR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FACE HI BACKER. HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ HE- I DALLY I DONT. HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI PLEASE SIR
I CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROVE NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
I LLEVA HI THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN HI NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN. I TRIED BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN AMBERG
FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER.
I WILL HI. PLEASE CALL THE UP
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY SIX KNOWS
ONE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
MOVING ON ITEM THREE FIFTEEN
CENTER COM LONGER. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIN SHINE AN ACT RELATING TO
JUVENILE CENTER COLOR THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT IN THE FREEZING
HOLES OF THIS CHAMBER I RISE TO
PRESENT K. B. FIVE FOUR SIX ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAN
TRYING THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PREVENT YOUTH EXITING THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS BY REQUIRING
COUNTY WELFARE AGENCIES TO
REPORT SPECIFIED INFORMATION
REGARDING A FOSTER YOUTH
HOUSING CIRCUMSTANCES TO THE
DEPENDENCY COURT. IN CALIFORNIA
APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND
YOUTH AGE OUT OF FOSTER CARE
AND AN ESTIMATED 65% BELIEVE
FOSTER CARE AT AGE EIGHTEEN
WITH NO PLACE TO CALL HOME
AFTER AGE OUT OF DEPENDENCY
JURISDICTION COUNTIES ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT A FINAL
STATUS REPORT TO THE COURT AB
FIVE FOUR SIX WOULD REQUIRE THE
FOLLOWING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE REPORT. ONE WHETHER
REFERRALS PROVIDED TO THE
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN SECURING STABLE
HOUSING AND IF NOT WHAT
ADDITIONAL REFERRALS ARE NEEDED
AND WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
DURATION OF THE ACQUIRED
HOUSING AND THREE ANY
ADDITIONAL REFERRALS OR
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED BY AN
ENTITY OTHER THAN THE COUNTY
WELFARE DEPARTMENT. WITH THE
INTENT OF SECURING STABLE
HOUSING THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION AND NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR COME LONGER
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON ITEM THREE FIFTEEN.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THIS
ITEM QUALIFIES FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IN THE OBJECTION TO
USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
THREE SEVENTEEN CENTER NEWMAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
STANLEYVILLE FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEE AN
ACT RELATING TO FOOD DELIVERY.
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT A B. FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF HIS FAMILY
MEMBER ALEX LEE. A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN A.
B. FOURTEEN FORTY FOUR
ADDRESSES ISSUES CREATED BY
ADVERTISING AROUND ONLINE
RESTAURANT LISTINGS BY TAKING A
THREE PRONGED APPROACH TO
PROTECT SMALL BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS. FIRST ITS PROVISIONS
WILL ENSURE THAT FOOD DELIVERY
PLATFORMS IN ONLINE DIRECTORIES
PROVIDE ACCURATE BUSINESS
INFORMATION TO HELP CONSUMERS
CONNECT DIRECTLY TO RESTAURANTS
IF THEY SO WISH SECOND IT
PROHIBITS THIRD PARTY PLATFORMS
FROM CHARGING RESTAURANTS FOR
ROUTING CALLS THAT DO NOT
RESULT IN A PAID ORDER. AND
THIRD IT REQUIRES THAT MOVING
FORWARD CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE
FOOD FACILITY IN A FOOD
DELIVERY PLATFORM SHALL INCLUDE
CLEAR INFORMATION FOR ALL FOR
ALL POSSIBLE CHARGES AND FEES
THAT MAY BE INCURRED BY
RESTAURANTS WITH WHOM THEY
ENTER INTO AGREEMENTS. MORE
THAN EVER AND ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS PANDEMIC MANY FAMILY OWNED
RESTAURANTS HAVE BECOME HEAVILY
RELIANT ON FOOD DELIVERY
SERVICES IN SOME CASES TO
ENSURE THEIR VERY SURVIVAL AND
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US TO
ENSURE THAT ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED HAVE A CLEAR
UNDERSTANDING IN ORDER TO MAKE
DECISIONS REGARDING THE
BUSINESSES. THAT SERVE THEIR
BEST INTERESTS A. B. FOURTEEN
FORTY FOUR WILL ENSURE THESE
BUSINESSES HAVE THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION AND INSIGHT TO DO
SO THE SMALL BUSINESS AND
CONSUMER RIGHTS COMMUNITIES
HAVE LOOK AT THE ISSUES RAISED
BY ONLINE ADVERTISING AROUND
MOM AND POP RESTAURANTS AND
SUPPORT A. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
FOUR I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
SIR NEWMAN MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BASE. BACKER HI
PORCHES FIVE BRADFORD I KERR BY
ADAM HI CORTESE I DALLY. DOT HI
THERE ALSO HI ADNAN. GLAZER
FIVE DOLLARS FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO I HER TADO
HI JONES NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LABOR I WILL MOAN HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN I NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN. BUT SHOW BOTH I CAN
HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH I
REVIEW. FIVE SKINNER I STERN ON
BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE
WINNERS FIVE WELL HI. PLEASE
CALL THE UP THE MEMBERS. FAITH
TALLY. EGGMAN HI GROVE.
MELINDA'S NIELSEN I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY FOUR NOS ONE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE IT IN THREE
TWENTY SIX RIGHT- AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY A I AM. THREE
THIRTY SIX THREE TWENTY SIX IS
SENATOR BRADFORD. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACT RELATING TO PEACE
OFFICERS. SIR BRADFORD THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AB TWENTY SIX
IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE
THAT'S THIS IS THOUSANDS
UNIVERSAL STANDARDS FOR- DVD
ENERGY INNER INTERCEDE BY
OFFICERS- WHAT IT MEANS FOR
PEACE OFFICER TRAINING ROUTINE-
WHEN WITNESSING THE EXCESSIVE
USE OF FORCE BY ANOTHER POLICE
OFFICER- CERTAIN OUTCOMES FOR
FAILURE TO INTERVENE. THE
AUTHOR- SOON HOLD HOLD AND HAS
WORKED WITH ALL OPPOSING
PARTIES B. C. H. P. POORER.
PLEASE PROTECTIVELY AND
ACCOUNTING SURE OF SACRAMENTO
OFFICE SO SHE'S IN A VERY US
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION AND BRING THEM.
TO NEUTRAL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. A DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
NELSON. MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
OF THE SENATE I WILL CONTINUE
TO URGE A NO VOTE
NOTWITHSTANDING SOME OF THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE BOWED
DOWN TO THIS INTIMIDATION AND
MAKING THE LIVES GREATER AT
RISK FOR OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS. THIS IS A BIT OF
A PART AND PARCEL OF THE MANY
ATTACKS ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
GOING ON ACROSS THE NATION
TODAY. THAT COUPLED WITH THE
REFORM OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
MAKING IT MORE CRIMINAL THAN
JUST. HAS PUT OUR COMMUNITIES
AT RISK I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR NELSON ANY OTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT WE WITNESS- THE WORLD
WITNESSED LAST YEAR THE CARLEY
OCHS OF THOSE THREE OFFICERS
WHO STOOD BY AND WATCHED DROID
FLORIDA BE MURDERED IN REAL
TIME. ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
REQUIRE THOSE OFFICERS WHO
WOULD WITNESS SUCH ACTS OF
VIOLENCE AND ABUSE OF FORCE OUR
USE OF FORCE I SHOULD SAY. TO
INTERCEDE AND STOP THOSE
ACTIONS THIS IS STRAIGHTFORWARD
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE WE SAW
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE OFFICER
BEATING A DOG IN PEOPLE
INTERCEDED QUICKER ON- THE MELT
TREATMENT OF THE STALL THAN
THEY DID FOR A HUMAN BEING THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA. AT KINS I BASE.
NO BACKER. I FOR JUST NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T.
QUARTET THE HI DALLY. DOT.
THEY'RE AWESOME I A COMMON I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO.
JONES NO KAMMERER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S NO MAN. NEWMAN
NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED. NO TAN I
FOUR TWENTY NINE I. ROSS. RUBIO
SKINNER. HI STERN HOMBURG WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER HI WELL
NOW. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN ARCHULETA.
CABRERO. DALLY NO DOT. GLAZER
HER TADO. MAN NEWMAN. RALPH
RUBIO. STERN AMBERG. SAM
BRADFORD MOVE THE CALL. MEMBERS
LIVING ON A FILE AND THREE
THIRTY SIX. CENTER CALM WATER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR KEN LONGER AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDICAL CENTER
COLOR. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ON AB THREE SIX
NINE THE STREET MEDICINE ACT
WHICH EXPANDS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE AND SOCIAL SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THERE ARE MORE
THAN SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
HOMELESSNESS PEOPLE HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING ON THE
STREETS IN LA COUNTY A 13% JUMP
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN THAT'S
MORE THAN ANY OTHER CITY IN THE
COUNTRY. BUT LA IS NOT THE ONLY
COUNTY SUFFERING FROM THIS
CRISIS THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS. FOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES WE
ARE NOT MEETING PEOPLE WHERE
THEY ARE AND AS A RESULT WE ARE
ALL PAYING THE PRICE. DURING
THE COURSE OF WORKING ON THIS
BILL I'VE HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE
OF TOURING WITH A NUMBER OF
STREET MEDICINE TEAMS I HAVE
GONE OUT INTO THE STREETS AND I
HAVE SEEN HOW THEY ADMINISTER
CARE. VISITS DAD WHO'S SERVED
DEALING WITH HYPERTENSION AND
IS A DIABETIC IF IT'S FATIMA
WHO'S- NOT ONLY BLIND- AND HIV
POSITIVE. BUT IN- DIFFICULT
RELATIONSHIPS AND ALSO
HOMELESS- TO LEWIS WHO'S
SUFFERING FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AILMENTS- TO KIANA
AND HER FAMILY WHO ARE LIVING
IN A BROKEN DOWN SUV. I HAVE
STRUGGLED TO GET HEALTH CARE
THAT THEY TRUST. THIS BILL
REALLY MEETS ALL OF THOSE FOLKS
WHERE THEY ARE. AND INSTEAD OF
ASKING THEM TO GO INTO A
TRADITIONAL BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITY AND TO JUMP THROUGH SO
MANY HOOPS THAT MAKE IT REALLY-
HARD FOR THEM TO GET CARE- THIS
MEETS THEM WHERE THEY ARE IN
THE STREETS IN THE ENCAMPMENTS.
ETCETERA MANY OF THE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS ARE
INSURED THROUGH MEDI CAL
HOWEVER EVEN WHILE INSURED 73%
OF THEM HAVE NEVER SEEN A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER. AND WHEN
THEY DO THEY ARE TURNED AWAY
BECAUSE OF BUREAUCRATIC
BARRIERS STARTING WITH THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS WITH
IDENTIFICATION CARDS THAT ARE
OFTENTIMES LOST OR STOLEN. WITH
BEING UNABLE TO OR UNWILLING TO
LEAVE THEIR BELONGINGS ON THESTREET IN ORDER TO GET TO THE
FACILITY TO GET CARE. OR BEING
SHAMED BECAUSE PERHAPS THE
DOCTOR OR THE ADMINISTRATORS OR
EVEN. FELLOW PATIENTS ARE NOT
REALLY INTERESTED IN HAVING
THEM IN THOSE FACILITIES. THE
MAINSTREAM HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
MODELS DO NOT FIT THE REALITY
OF THE STREETS AND SO IF WE ARE
GOING TO REALLY HELP. THEN IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RE ENGINEER
PORTIONS OF OUR DELIVERY SYSTEM
TO MEET FOLKS WHERE THEY ARE.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THE TWENTY FIVE
PLUS STREET MEDICINE TEAMS
ACROSS THIS STATE WHO ARE DOING
JUST THAT. THE JEWS OF IT ALL
IS THAT RECOGNIZING THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF ON HOUSE POPULATIONS.
THIS BILL WILL EXTEND MEDIC COW
PRESUMPTIVE ELIGIBILITY TO THE
HOMELESS IT WILL REMOVE ID CARD
REQUIREMENTS FOR RECEIVING
CARE. AND WILL ALLOW AND HOUSE
PATIENTS TO RECEIVE
COMPREHENSIVE MEDICAL BENEFITS
OUTSIDE THE WALLS OF A
TRADITIONAL MEDICAL CLINIC. I
pBIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
COMMITTEES AND ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. AND THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
SINGLE GROUP IN OPPOSITION BUT
A LOT MORE IMPORTANT. I'M PROUD
TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF SO MANY
FOLKS WERE AND HOUSE WHO ARE
LIVING IN CAMPS AND ON THE
STREETS EVERY DAY AND WHEN THIS
WAS HEARD ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO WHEN IT
PASSED OFF THE FLOOR WE WERE
TOLD. THERE WAS AN ENCAMPMENT
THAT WAS BEING ADMINISTERED
STREET MEDICINE AND THEY ALL
STOPPED AND CHEERED. FOR ALL OF
US ARE PASSING THIS BILL ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE THEY ARE
LISTENING TO US NOW. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. FOR EIGHTY THREE SIX
NINE. THANK YOU SIR CALLER ID
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM THREE THIRTY SIX. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I HAD
CANS HI BABES. BACKER I PORCHES
BRADFORD I CALLED THE OTHER HI
CORTEZ V. I. DALLY. DODD FIVE
TORONTO BY ADMIN I GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROSS. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO. HER TADO
HI JONES. CAMCORDER I LAYERED I
LLEVA I THE MON. HI WIRE.
MELINDA'S MAN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. BUT SHOW A VOGUE HI
TAM. FORTINO FIVE ROTH I RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. I STERN I'M BERG HI
HI MIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER I
WILL HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BASED. FOR JUST. BALLY
WESO I JONES. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. NIELSEN PAN. STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO GO BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS CENTER DELHI FOR
WHAT PURPOSE THE RICE. THANK
YOU PRESIDENT- I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RECONSIDER
FOR RECONSIDERATION OF AB FIVE
SIXTEEN FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY
FOUR. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO- OFFERING
RECONSIDERATION ON ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTEEN ITEM TWO
SEVENTY FOUR. FOR SENATOR DELHI.
NO NO OBJECTIONS TO THE MOTION.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
MEMBERS WERE GONNA MOVE. YES
SIR WHAT I HAVE ONE LAST TO
REQUEST ALSO I WANTED TO LET
ALL THE MEMBERS KNOW THAT
THEY'RE A BAG OF PEACHES OUT
HERE FOR YOU TO GRAB ON THE WAY
OUT. AND I PLEASE ENJOY. THANK
IS THERE DAILY- JUST FOR THE
MEMBERS PURPOSES WE ARE NOT
ADJOURNED. IS ANXIOUS AS MR
DALLI IS TO GET US OUT OF HERE-
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSENT CALENDAR LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN. WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE
CALLS FIRST SO. LET'S GO BACK
AND LIVE SOME CALLS WE HAVE
SEVERAL ITEMS ON CALL. STAND BY
FOR THOSE ITEMS. FIVE MEMBERS
WERE GOING BACK TO THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE HAVE
SEVERAL GOVERNORS APPOINTMENTS
ON CALL. WE'RE GONNA GO TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE. IF WE
CAN LET THE CALL PLEASE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I FORGES HI BY ADAM I
DALLY I. THE CARD. I WESSEL I.
CAN LONGER I LAMONT. I
MELINDA'S I NIELSEN. I FORTINO
I STERN. SIZE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FIVE. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WITHOUT. I
THE MON. I MELINDA'S. I
FOURTEEN TINO I STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED OR
MOVING TO FILE AND THREE TWENTY
SIX MEMBERS THIS IS A B. TWENTY
SIX FILE ADAM THREE TWENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. BY ADAM. DODD
GLAZER. HER TADO. MAN NEWMAN.
RALPH NEWMAN HI. ROSS I YEAH.
STERN AMBERG- LASER EYE SURGERY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA I CABALLERO. DODD I
HER TADO. MAN RUBIO. STERN
AMBERG HI. SIZE TWENTY SIX
KNOWS NINE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING BACK TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE LIMONEIRA. I
MELINDA'S I FORTINO I TURNED.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE IT KNOWS ZERO
GOVERNOR APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY NINE GOVERNOR
APPOINTMENT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. LIMONEIRA I
MELINDA'S I FORTINO. I STERN
HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON A FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY ONE GOVERNORS
APPOINTMENT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ADMIN. HI
MELINDA'S I FORTINO I STERN.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE OH ZERO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON A FILE
AND ONE FORTY NINE SENATOR
RUBIO SCR ELEVEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MELINDA'S
I NEWMAN. I FORTUNE TINO. I
TURN HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
HAVE THREE CONSENT CALENDARS
THAT WERE TAKING UP TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE FIRST
CONCERT CALENDAR SECOND DAY.
AND THE SECRETARY WILL PLEASE
READ THE ITEMS. THIS IS CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER EIGHT. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FORTY EIGHT.
1-483-296-2983 1-938-142-5430.
1-435-404-5403 663-797-9889
EIGHT EIGHTEEN. TEN TWENTY FOUR
ELEVEN FORTY NINE ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
THIRTEEN FORTY NINE THIRTEEN
SIXTY TO THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
FORTINO NINE FIFTEEN FORTY ONE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS
AT. NINETEEN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION SEVEN
ASSEMBLY BILLS AT 340-549-4620
FOUR AT 934-992-1290. THREE
TWELVE NINETY EIGHT THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN FOURTEEN FORTY
THREE. AND ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
OH SEVEN ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY FIVE. SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY TWO SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION THREE SENATE
BILL. FOUR NINETY EIGHT SEVEN
FIFTY SIX EIGHT TWENTY ONE AND
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION TEN.
THE COMMAND STRUCTURES IN
OBJECTION TO YOU USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THESE
CONSENT ITEMS. SAYING NO
OBJECTION THESE ITEMS PASS
THERE I USED TO BE NINE KNOWS
ZERO MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR NUMBER
NINE. SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER NINE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTIONS AT. THIRTY TO FORTY
FORTY SEVEN FIFTY TO SIXTY FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN AND ASSISTS AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY NINE. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS WISHING OF- ANYTHING
OFF OF CONSENT. SEEING NONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ARCHULETA. ADKINS FIVE
BABIES. HI BECKER. HI PORGES.
HI BRADFORD IS STAND BY MEMBERS
THIS IS SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER EIGHT I'M SORRY
NUMBER NINE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER NINE SECRETARY
PLEASE CONTINUE. BRADFORD I
HAVE I HAD A I PROTESTING I
DALLY. HI TODD. I TORONTO HI
ADNAN I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES.
I GROSS FIVE FIRSTS BERG FIVE
WEST SO HI HURTADO HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I LLEVA I
THE MON. I REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S
I MEN I NEWMAN I NEED NIELSEN I
A SHOW OF BOTH. HI PAM I PERSON
TINA I ROSS I RUBIO. HI SKINNER
STERN NUMBER FIVE WACO SKI I
WINNER FIVE WELL I SOMETIMES
REPUBLICANS ROCK CONSENT. TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I. SKINNER
STERN. HIGHS THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO MEASURES PASS. MOVING ON
TO THE FINAL CONSENT CALENDAR
OF THE EVENING CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER TEN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILLS AT
353-269-2734 FIFTY THREE EIGHT
THIRTEEN EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
ASSEMBLY BILLS. 1-499-151-1780
EIGHT ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWELVE THIRTY THREE
AND IT'S ONLY BILLS TWO SIXTY
THREE AND FIFTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY- IS
THERE ANY I ANY MEMBERS WISHING
TO PULLING ITEMS OFF THIS
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING NONE
THIS ALSO- IS QUALIFIES FOR
UNANIMOUS CONSENT FOR HIM SO
CALL. HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
MEASURES PASS MEMBERS I THINK
WERE WRAPPING UP. SENATOR
ATKINS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS THE DESK IS CLEAR. MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
CONGRATULATIONS ON AN
EXCELLENT- PRESIDING OF THIS
CHAMBER TODAY AND COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK WE GOT THROUGH A LARGE
NUMBER OF BILLS. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THAT EFFORT SO
THEREFORE OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TEN AM
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU CENTER AT KANSAS SENATE
WILL BE ADJOURNED WE WILL
RECONVENE WEDNESDAY AT TEN AM.
AND NOW YOU CAN GET YOUR
PEACHES FROM SENATOR DOLLAR.